[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
so
[Music]
foreign
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
it
[Music]
nice
hey
[Music]
come on
hey
[Music]
bye
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
so
do
[Music]
so
more
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
my
[Music]
nice
hey
[Music]
oh
my
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
thank you
woah
[Music]
hmm
so
[Music]
all
[Applause]
[Music]
um
boom
[Music]
[Applause]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
that's right
[Music]
hey
howdy folks
it's that time of year welcome to
gamespot's coverage of summer game fest
or also known as
key three as we like to call it here
because jeff keeley took it upon himself
e3 didn't happen this year but jeff
keeley is happening this year jeff key
three
is happening this year i'm kurt nevina
and joining me today is davonte chisholm
who came in from new jersey welcome in
the flesh in arms reach yeah i like been
we saw a little clip of it at a
playstation state of play last week i am
all in for a new horror experience like
i want to ruin my family's christmas by
like just screaming in the middle of the
night because i've scared myself with
the game oh i just thought that was just
a thing you're like
i just want to ruin my family's
christmas
and show them closer protocol put it on
screen be like hey fam here we are
uh this is i mean this is the the
spiritual successor some may say we have
the same person who made dead space
they're one of the lead producers
executive producer of dead space
uh here kind of kicking this thing into
gear only a month before a month or is
it a month prior to the release of dead
space remake before um yeah it is before
so it's coming out december
um and then we're gonna have yeah the
dead space remake in early 2023 i'm
excited for both both can obviously
exist in the same world but uh you know
it's just something exciting it's
something new like while it'll be fun to
go back to dead space and see it look
all shiny and
look at that gore and delicious 4k you
know there's something to be said about
this delicious school
just i just want to see a new horror
experience is it cake or is it gore and
delicious 4k uh
that show oh my god what was it no it's
just the fact that it's like
i wanna i wanna understand about the um
the pub g
side oh well i mean no longer yeah they
took they took that out
yeah i do want to understand then they
were like no just kidding
it was just a way that i don't know
getting into this like ice but maybe we
all realize that there is a there's a
there's clearly an urge there's a want
for dead space something a space horror
space body horror space gooey horror
even for someone like me that just
doesn't how gross can we get it yes yes
and that's the thing too that's a game
that like uh
we only learned about i feel like fairly
recently and then the next thing i know
it's like i mean we got announcement
what was it last year i think
yeah something like that it was the
first yeah i think it started off as a
xbox exclusive as well yeah
and then you know we only got gameplay a
week ago or so and now we're getting the
game this year uh devante what are you
looking forward to what do you want to
see that you know that's happening today
hey i got to give the basic answer i got
to say
modern warfare 2. if you're excited yeah
i it took me a while i
i drifted away from call of duty
and then
the first modern warfare well the redo
of modern warfare brought me back in
so now here we are modern warfare 2 i'm
i'm ready for it i'm ready to jump back
into it and it seems promising it seems
like they're changing a lot with the
engine and revamping warzone as well so
yeah it's it's up there for me the um we
you you said it before we went live you
said if it was cold war too
you were in new york yeah
after after modern warfare yeah not to
throw shade at the ones that you know
came before modern warfare 2 but
vanguard cold war they just weren't they
weren't the hit for yeah they they
weren't hitting for me and you could
tell from
the public's reaction to them that they
weren't really hitting for a lot of call
of duty fans either they were really
just placeholders it felt like and
the last one they kind of like did in a
big way was xcom chimera which was a
quite different from the xcom one and
two games but very very like interesting
twist on the formula it feels like
they're moving in different directions
after xcom one and two and so i'm super
super excited to see what they do with
the marvel property um yeah they they
want to focus a little more on
storytelling and characterization it
seems which has always been kind of the
case but they kind of left it to
the player to rename their characters
and build the stories so now i'm excited
to see what they do when they actually
have the opportunity to work a proper
narrative in there and they know that
they the key thing that the original
reveal trailer showed is they know that
people playing want to spend time with
these characters they have that whole
base um where you can hang out and chat
to iron man
and obviously i want to spend at least
30 to 40 hours just talking to blade so
i hope that that that is uh allowed for
me
i mean jeff kelly's got wizard sleeves
doctor strange sleeves
uh to pour things out we've had so it's
like dc's had i mean mostly just
rocksteady has had a good old hold on
some remarkable dc games and then marvel
spider-man insomniac and spider-man came
along and there's a there's obviously a
deliberate push we've seen over the past
couple years for marvel games to kind of
come back and we had like a diverse
amount of like faces over what we've
seen between guards in the galaxy um
last year i believe and now we have this
coming out is this is do we we don't we
don't actually know that much we're
gonna be seeing more today well that's
that's the plan that's the hopes that's
the hopes and dreams personally
if i may
which fire that's a game that was
announced back in 2017
uh the same developers as the vanishing
of ethan carter that's the game i'm most
excited for that's or at least like
that's the one that i saw on this list i
was like i forgot i didn't forget it but
i've been anticipating it i've been
wanting to see this game for a while it
kind of gives me boomer shooter yeah
dark fantasy gothic vibes some of the
devs who worked on it uh who were who
also worked on the vantage of ethan
carter which is a great game
by the way if you don't know it great
detective um spooky wookie kind of it's
on my backlog oh come on
he feels so good if you feel comfortable
you should play it okay uh but which
fire is definitely very left field from
what the vanish of ethan carter is which
is just a no attack
kind of investigative storytelling thing
but which fire i don't know if we have i
don't know if we have gameplay or b-roll
of that but that game
all i know is that it's got skeletons
old-fashioned looking guns with magic
and dark stuff is it too scary for me i
don't know all right let's just get it
i'll i'll give it a try then yeah i'll
give it a try i mean boomer shooters are
coming back they are ish i mean if
they're done right we have we have we
have a whole array of them but that said
moving on there's
i know jeff keely temp your expectations
but there's still hopes that there might
be a mystery might be a thing to slip
out um we've already had one
slip up i think we should probably just
get that out of the way um there's this
little game
called the last of us never heard of it
uh but it's now being called the last of
us part one this morning it looks like
we had a leak we have a release date
september 22nd
um we're gonna be expecting to see
a full scale i don't actually really
know yet
how how much scale of a of a remake is
going to be or looks like from the
ground up
round up
lucy we watch we all watch the trailer
it's fine we can admit i didn't have it
yeah i didn't actually watch it
um yeah it looks like it's remade from
the ground up my i guess my question
would be is like is it too soon for our
last of us remake i mean hbo but we have
an hbo show i guess we do have an hbo
show which i'm very excited about i
can't wait to see pedro pascal as joel
but like
it's nine years old they re-released it
on ps4
i think we have a ps3 we got a ps4 we
have a new thing i would say though is
that like
i really hope it feels like the last of
us part 2 because going back to part the
last of us is actually very difficult
because
it feels like a game from 2013 and i've
said this multiple times before i know
i'll probably get some flack for it
online but like i don't think naughty
dog really figured out how to make a
game feel fluid
sorry i didn't think the shooting was
particularly good i don't think they
really mastered that until uncharted 4
lost legacy um but now they have that
knowledge and the fact that ellie
in part two is way more mobile and like
climbing and stuff i really hope they
can add that fluidity in uh to the game
the first one yeah i think that's
exactly what we're gonna get like the
the screenshot of the box is out there
and it's it's not just called the last
of us the last of us remastered it's now
retroactively it's called the last of us
part one and you know that makes perfect
sense they are no doubt striving for
cohesion between the first and second
game which is what is currently missing
like there's very few games that
i mean a lot of games sequel to sequel
these days there's like a thread between
them that you can go from one to the
other and
and back and forth quite easily because
mechanics don't change in a big way and
neither does aesthetic um from game to
game whereas last of us one to last of
us two is a massive massive leap for
naughty dog and in a lot of ways the the
kind of industry as well um in terms of
how it plays how it feels and even the
storytelling and it makes perfect sense
for them who you know when they first
announced the last there was part two a
lot of the kind of discussion from them
around it was we want to try and
approach it in like a filmic way where
it's kind of like godfather one
godfather two and and right now that the
way that last of us one exists even with
the remastered one it kind of is the
antithesis of that it's a jarring um
kind of transition from one game to the
other so if they do want to hit that
ambition of we've got this like hbo
style filmic experience they need to
create experience that um it has a
little more cohesion between the first
one and the second one it makes perfect
sense for them to go back and turn use
all of the
knowledge and design and
the the tech that they created for last
of us too in one so that people can go
from one to the other and feel like it's
a flowing cohesive experience devante
you're a big last of us fan yeah i'm
pretty sure i've heard not a dog in las
vegas so you've whispered to me just
before the show began what do you think
it needs to be like what do you think
this this uh last of us part one
not remake not remaster
what do you think it needs to have to
like to get you someone who's an already
existing fan to like boot it up again or
you could just be on a bash like i just
want to play it again yeah that's that's
kind of all it is for me is like it
doesn't need to do anything extra or
different um
similar to what lucy and tam said like
just kind of tighten up those controls
and and like
make crafting and inventory and all of
that stuff movement feel the way it does
in part two and then it's just like i'm
just really going back for nostalgia's
sake you know just to see it in a a
shiny new paint of coat similar to
how everyone is going back to all of
like the resident evil remakes right now
and things like that or at least there
was like 20 years would do okay i mean
some of those like i mean so there could
be something to be said over the
residential 4 remake which again is not
being
you know said to be a remake it is just
simply being shown as resident before
yeah it's this thing that's you know
like we which we'll be seeing more of on
monday um
so so there's been whispers up on
twitter by capcom um you know i think
last of us uh i was just talking about
this this morning it's like the last of
us part two specifically is like this
perfect mirroring of taking
naughty dog's
incredible cinematic storytelling yeah
um and i know tam you're not the biggest
fan of how to controls but like i really
thought last week's part two was like a
ballet of violence and like i really
felt like it was
like a beautiful way to like dance
around and stealth and like get up and
do all these things and that's like
again lucy said this like there's
something just so much more versatile
about how the way ellie moves and that's
probably because of ellie and the way i
mean like they just really went on that
and if they can somehow joel's if they
can somehow take that same approach to
how joel would really move in a way uh
to this remake without you know like
harkening it down too much i think
that'd be sweet and besides it's like
we're gonna have a whole new audience of
people who are gonna probably just be
learning about last of us they're going
to see the show
and then jump in and we're getting it
this year sales numbers are going to go
up like witcher days
yeah that's crazy i also got to get
those jewel sense integrations too you
know yeah i just want to feel i just
like want to feel the controller just
crunches one of those you know
mushroom what are they called sprouters
boys clickers clickers yeah
sprouters
but real real quick the um and similar
to what tam was saying with like the
cohesion and the link between the two
parts i find it very interesting that
ellie is huge on the cover of this one
whereas before she was kind of like so
you're gonna say ellie is huge now
you know sharing the the cover before
but now she's gigantic and he's smaller
even though he's the one you're playing
as in this one but i find that
interesting they're definitely really
trying to grab people that may have
jumped in on part two and are going back
to experience this
but also that was a story i remember
back in 2013 that naughty dog had to
actually fight to even get ellie on the
cover
yeah and they did and it's like a sign
of the times thing that we can have
ellie front and center
grizzle huge bearded grizzled
buff huge huge alley here to pull the
weight
and that's how you track how like
ruthless you are so by the end of the
game you're like there's blood on your
hands you turn and ellie's like 20 foot
tall and you're like oh god if they did
i know we're talking about last of us a
lot but if they did a roll switch for
this remake that would actually be
pretty remarkable yeah now that they're
gonna do it
but they could we don't know i don't
even know if we're gonna be seeing it
today the official trailer that was lead
well we already saw it so yeah some of
us didn't go surprise i'm here i'm i'm
i'm here for the genuine surprise i
didn't even know it was leaked until
just now just kidding uh lucy
i'm gonna kick it over to you because
you know
there's still there's still chance for a
secret or two there's still a chance for
somebody for surprises
we have two hours this is the summer
game festival is two hours i'm not
saying that all these games can't fill
up that time but like
dwayne the rock johnson's expect to be
there we'll get to that in a second but
i don't think he's gonna be on for like
15 minutes he's gonna probably do a
thirty second hey
fortnight fortnite movie
what do we think that's gonna be
this is the fortnite movie
uh uh probably
what do you think spy hunter isaac what
what is uh dwayne the rock johnson
representing or what is he gonna do what
movie what he's gonna announce possible
movie announcement something well they
did the black adam trailer yesterday
yeah it would be black adam i guess but
i kind of want him to just cut a promo
on jeff kelly while he's up there as if
he's like old school with a rock just
telling
jeff kelly that if he doesn't smoke or
jeff kelly just takes the place of bill
gates yeah and he takes him to like
a hotel or wherever it was from back in
the day
um and keeps doing the rock's eyebrow at
jeff keeley that would be what i want to
see most but in all likelihood he'll be
like hey i'm the dwayne the rock johnson
you might remember me from
uh shows like the wwe and movies like
fast and furious the one you may know me
you may know me as the man beefing with
vin diesel um
uh i'm gonna be in fortnight and uh
maybe maybe he'll be like
yeah he's he's around there he's like
one of the characters and maybe he'll be
like we're actually also making a
fortnight movie and i will be the main
character
pili the banana i am i'm exposing i'm
just i'm completely throwing myself like
i don't even know i knew he was in it
yeah don't know if he's playable yeah
i'm pretty sure yeah sure uh yeah but
we're gonna get fortnite movie he's
gonna jump out he's gonna peel a banana
uh yeah what is it twerk dab bailey dab
on the way out dab yeah anyways back on
back on to what could be a surprise not
just doing it because we we kind of know
that joey's gonna be there lucy
what's what's the big surprise that you
want to see what's the thing you hope
you know far-fetched crap is something
that you don't know that you the the oh
i mean that i don't know did i write in
the dark i think i wrote the new kojima
game like he's been
he's been posting i mean norman reedus
was like oh yeah i'm working on uh death
stranding too
um which
i don't know if that's what this is
gonna be but you know kojima's been
posting that he's like back doing motion
capture with a bunch of actors um
or at least that's the rumor that's the
rumor that's going to be mark quality
and as someone who is watching the
leftovers for the first time i really
had like a leo moment like pointing in
the screen like huh
um
but no i i'm really i'm really stoked
i'm really interested to see what that
could possibly be i feel like if if
anything is going to get announced with
regards to kojima it's going to be on
jeff's stage we did a video with jeff a
couple weeks ago we asked him 20
questions
first off the bat we asked him who his
best friend is and he said hideo kojima
so it broke everyone else's hearts yeah
yeah
it would be terrible kojima didn't say
that back
okay
sorry joseph says hideo kojima um
oh yeah that's true but no i think
whatever it's going to be i think that's
going to be interesting like you said
it's two hours of show and kanji uh
nakajima jeff keeley said you know
temperature expectation but i honestly
think that is just a state of the video
game world right now is that like you
can tell people exactly what to expect
and they will still go oh it wasn't
enough blah blah blah and so i feel like
he's probably gonna have a great show he
always does
and i think he's just telling people to
temper their expectations anyway just to
avoid any
mud slinging because that's what people
love to do at these kind of things he's
going to come out wearing some fly kicks
although he might just reserve those for
game awards i was thinking oh no no no
he's going to see him come
and then we give him a 5 out of five and
then a new jeff kelly meme is born i
just want to know what his regular shoe
game is like
it's pretty good
i mean every time i've seen jeff he's
always got pretty good shoes but he does
i mean again like we did 20 questions
with him he does have a stylist for the
big events
and his stylist it does like jason momoa
and steve luke so
i want to see him use his own shoes yeah
i want to see jeff keeley come out and
whatever outfit they pick for jason
momoa
basically no shirt on like get an
oversized suit yes tam you're the kojima
you're a kojima
man friend person
uh
i am friends with kadena
let's just spread that
what do you think uh as kojima's best
friend tam what do you think like what
do you think the chances are that we're
going to see i mean at all see anything
one kojima related into what is your uh
your weigh-in on the possibility of a
horror game rather than death stranding
two i i think that we are due a kojima
appearance at a jeff keeley show the
last time
he was mentioned was that time when he
was um
like not allowed or around if i remember
correctly um we're thinking of you
yeah yeah time is a flat circle at this
point so i can't remember if that was
that was like before death running
became a big thing but um he's not been
around for a long time in a jeff keeley
thing so we are doing him popping up and
being going hi everyone hello jeff my
best friend um anthem my best friend uh
so hopefully we'll get at least that out
of it whether we we get to see the game
i'm hopeful um at the very least we i
would suspect if he does show up he'll
be like i'm working on something special
um maybe uh a screenshot or something
like just a snippet um the the whether
he's gonna be making that that horror
game if it feels like a dead cert at
this point um if you think about it the
thing that most people were most excited
about um
prior to the whole um
uh fallout with konami was him working
on pt and there was a lot around that
project that got people excited
namely like working with del taro and
more importantly junji ito um and i
think there's been a lot of people
wanting to see him return to that idea
or at the very least wanting to see him
work in the survival horror or horror
genre a bit more he always flirts with
it he's had horror
aspects of horror in metal gear solid
three um
with the dream sequence and obviously
there's that one chapter in medgar solid
five
which is quite intense and then pt as
well and he was originally going to do
silent hills so i think he as much as
anyone else and also people who are
funding him will know that um a horror
thing is is top of mind for people who
want something out of kojima so that
seems like a dead certainty and and
having the folks that worked on death
stranding involved in to some degree
also works because that world can
support something a little more horrific
and a survival hurry and you know kind
of like that kind of aesthetic as well
um there's parts of the stranding that
are already quite unsettling and i think
you could like push it up a bit more um
so it wouldn't be a stretch to have a a
horror game existing in that universe or
they could just be moving on and being
like let's just grab those same you know
our actors and use them for different
things and try and make it a an
anthology starting so it could work
we're overdue i mean we're overdue for a
kojima horror game like there's no
secret that he wants it
uh i think it was during game awards
grandma del toro threw out like this
this like this kind of like kind of off
the cuff line being like we want to make
a horror game oh well i guess we
couldn't it came off really like wow
what is that alluding to what are you so
what are you saying there but that said
you know we have uh you're not the
horror guy devonte so i'm sorry it's
okay you know i i accept that i'm a
scaredy cat um and one day you know
i'll i'll get over it or i won't you
just signed up you just signed up that
means defunte is our designated horror
playing boy well at least i can hide in
a different
horror games can't cross state lines yes
no that's that well you just signed
yourself up to deal with it okay i've
i've been through the ringer doing that
stuff i love horror games even though i
don't handle them well but tam you
mentioned you know we want to see kojima
do survival horror horror is just horde
never left
the game zeitgeist but it does feel over
the past couple years specifically uh
that like survival horror
is really trying is like really making a
much needed comeback yeah
um we had i mean it kind of i mean i
don't know if i could be wrong here but
i felt like it really started to come in
uh circle with the resident evil 2
remake specifically maybe resident evil
7 maybe yeah i'll give resume seven
credit yeah for sure but i really feel
like it started to sing
with that from spot though we have alan
wake two which is gonna be a
full-fledged survival [__] that was
supposed to be seen i know i i mean i
like had a meltdown i usually don't get
too excited during announcements but
when sam likes about just seeing sam
lake kind of like gives me chills i mean
but also like the max payne remix as
well like there's so much sam late
coming over the next few years um and
also a tv show alan wake tv show signed
through amc we have a lot going to be
drowning in lake
trout yes those are going to be drowning
in lake and allen allen wake lakes max
payne's lake um
but uh
if we got this if we got this wave i
know this doesn't help you devonte i'm
just going to keep apologizing yeah no
don't if we get this wave of residual
four
we get uh i mean we're going to get
residual village vr we're going to get
alan wake to survival horror if we get a
kojima survival horror then we'll get we
get cholesterol protocol this year and
then dead space remake next year yep
it's a time for me to be alive me and
lucy are just having a great time
yeah i mean we're gonna be alive until
we scare ourselves gonna ruin everyone's
christmas apparently that's the plan
get a booty
but in terms of before we got two and a
half minutes going in right before the
show begins also just wanna let everyone
know that we are gonna be having a quick
little post show afterwards and then
we're gonna lead right into the day of
the devs day of the devil's going to be
starting so if you want to watch that
we're also going to be streaming that so
you can make sure to still watch it here
at gamespot
but we'll also be chatting around uh for
a little bit and then after that it's
going to be back to devonta and i um but
before we move into that
i want to know if there's anything
you're hoping to see that's not in that
little list
something that is not on the low list
but
we do know
that
focus entertainment will be there
i want to see a plate tail requiem
that's kind of horror-like
a little bit yeah
luckily i'm not afraid of like mice and
or rats in that way but yeah you can
handle a wave of them like thousands of
them thousands of them
that game really the first one really
surprised me though i it didn't seem
like a game that i would love and you
know bless game pass
downloaded booted it up and just started
to really
fall in love with the world and the
characters and the rats um and i'm i'm
i'm hyped to see
the second one i didn't think i didn't
think a second one would pop up and then
you got a thing for you got a thing for
like yeah it's like i i have a thing for
certain horror i guess we like i'm
talking like even you know conceptually
it's like it's like big sister looking
out for a little brother yeah pseudo
daddy looking out for pseudo daughter
yeah same concept yeah follows me to the
witcher 2. yeah you're talking about
plague tale you're talking about
bioshock here
all of them yeah all of them because i
love bioshock too
yeah big that's just my thing figures
looking after little ones yep apparently
devonte a man of heart i'm looking out
for somebody clearly i'm like a father
and i don't even know it
i hope hello
hello to all my children out there
all of my rat children i love my wrath
all of my rugrats
uh tim
what do you want to see
what are you hoping and what's the
biggest thing you know what i want to
see it's a big surprise
the big surprise we had it last time
jeff keeley was around he delivered in a
big way he gave us alden ring i think
it's time for jeff keeley to deliver the
other the second part of the the elden
ring dlc it's been a while as the game's
been out it's got a lot of momentum it
is likely going to be game of the year
pretty much all right
it's time it's time uh it's time for us
to possibly see we have five seconds to
go folks we're here at game spot
covering summer game fest thank you for
being here over to you jeff keely let's
kick it
and here we
go
hello everybody i'm jeff keely and this
is summer game fest a live showcase of
what's next in the wide wide world of
video games we are live here in los
angeles or whether you're streaming from
home or watching inside an imax theater
welcome to our showcase event over the
next few hours we'll give you updates on
the games you love be joined by special
developer guests and yes have a few
surprises along the way too now what i
love about this show is that it's a true
cross industry showcase whether you play
on xbox pc playstation switch or mobile
will have games for you it doesn't
matter your platform of choice we're all
here to come together as one community
that simply loves the art of amazing
video games
the biggest franchises in the industry
are here like call of duty you'll get
introduced to exciting new worlds new
teams and will make room for small
independent developers who we think
deserve the spotlight too if we do this
right hopefully you'll discover a few
new games to put on your wish list and
even if you don't get every announcement
that you desire let's face it you're not
going to get everything today but we've
got a lot of great stuff so let's get
started
over 30 years ago capcom street fighter
hit arcades and ever since this
legendary japanese fighting game series
has continued to evolve street fighter 6
is coming in 2023 and right now we're
excited to officially confirm a
character coming to the game and show
you the exclusive first gameplay footage
enjoy
[Music]
you will know what hits you let me have
some fun
let's get this mission started
got you in my sights
neutralized
i'm just on another level
it's all about the comb all right next
it's time for a brand new game
announcement here at summer game fest
check this out
[Music]
sergeant leo alvarez of the cmle recon
squad
our mission was to enter the tantalus
base locate the comsat relay and bring
it back online
we found the relay
but there was a
problem
get that door closed now private in the
hall
close again nothing gets in here
ray didn't make it
release he support peace
take the lead
oh
this ain't good
what we found was
a new kind of evil
and it found us first
what
this
wasn't human
go go
hold that door sergeant
son of a
i don't know what i saw in there
but i know when i close my eyes
i still see it
now everyone's dead
[Music]
and someone needs to know
that was aliens dark descent and it's
coming in 2023 to console and pc
next two years ago at the game awards we
revealed the callisto protocol from the
creative forces behind the dead space
franchise today i am thrilled to get to
show you the first raw game play
alongside its creator glenn schofield
but first here's the quote-unquote
scofield cut of the brand new trailer
with a little more gore
[Music]
so
take a look outside
did you know that they call callisto the
dead moon
dead just like you would have been if i
hadn't fished you out of that wreck
so whatever you're holding on to right
there
that's your old life
you gotta let that go
because
your new
life
is entirely
in my hands
[Music]
i'm just trying to give you a chance
at rebirth
[Music]
oh
i just love that last part
gives me chills every time
[Applause]
so
welcome
to your new home
[Music]
that's right we know what you wanted to
see and joining me now glenn schofield
striking distance glenn uh first of all
congratulations this game looks
absolutely incredible and i gotta say
the fact that you have built this team
this studio new ip shipping this
december all in covid blows me away so
congratulations yeah thanks man
thanks for having us i really do
appreciate it jeff um and you know for a
second just give me a second
you know i want to thank you uh for all
you've done for the game industry uh all
these years man i i think i've known you
like 16 17 years now and uh
um you've been an ambassador
um you've amplified new games new
studios and uh i i just wanted to thank
you i really do appreciate it thank you
it's not about me it's about you guys
yeah i know i appreciate that thank you
so much and yeah it's so fun to do these
shows and to show this game so people
saw the trailer but what i'm so excited
today is that you just brought a raw
gameplay sequence this game is in
development and people can be blown away
i think when they see it but tell us a
bit about what are we going to see today
yeah we got a couple minutes of uh like
you said like we're all game play um
it's two segments in the first half of
the game uh one is the med bay another
one is a power station and you're gonna
see uh some
new enemies some brutality some uh just
about everything we were showcasing a
new weapon called the grip it's a like a
gravity gun but it picks up the enemies
and it shoves them into giant fans it
rips them apart it's great and uh and
then check out the uh
the nice ending we have where we uh you
know we usually will kill our main
character jacob and in a very unique way
and uh
just for a second i i want to thank the
team man like you said through covid
through everything else the dedication
the hard work uh you guys are amazing
thank you very much oh well glenn i
gotta say again you know what you guys
are shipping this year this looks like a
world-class next-gen game uh it's it's
rare that teams are bringing something
out like this this year and
let's let the footage speak for itself
ben schofield striking distance here it
is the first gameplay of the callisto
protocol
oh
uh
[Music]
so
touch
oh my god that just happened all right
moving on
this october call of duty modern warfare
2 arrives infinity ward is once again
returning to its roots for a modern day
action game and today we're about to
show you the world premiere of its
gameplay with a level play through to
tell us more let's head to the port of
long beach to check in with johanna
ferris the head of call of duty
hi everyone in 2019 modern warfare
changed everything and on october 28th
we usher in a new era of call of duty
with the launch of modern warfare 2. we
are back we are bigger and we are
bringing the entire team
price
gaz soap alejandro
and of course ghost we needed a stage
big enough to debut call of duty in a
whole new way
inspired by the world we're about to
enter
oil rigs cargo ships and staggering odds
are just the beginning
here is modern warfare 2.
[Music]
all right
disarm that missile be ready for
anything
this could be a draft
actual we're set
guppy get to work
all shadows that this was on this
platform
i want full containment
you've got three eq internal two one
making entry
so cut right clear through
room clear coming out
channel one moving to the
[Music]
we're moving to the main deck what's
your status boarding the ship with
shadow three now roger
eyes on that container
they're gonna launch that missile
it's first stage there's no time all
shadows all
shadows off
move to the helicopter
[Music]
oh
my god
clear
actually
open
are the controls
on that damn ship
actually we got a problem
on the ship you have your orders son
stop that launch
your position we're taking effective
fire the lv will be hot
once we're on deck we push to the bridge
fast secure those controls stop this
vessel yep how do we board
let's have ourselves a gunfight
missile patrols are on the bridge you
have to stop the lawn
copy that
reloading
[Music]
between them
actually don't
foreign
check it controls are internal
all right stand back this is shadow one
going explosive on bridge edge
three two one execute
[Music]
pre-order now and get early access to
the open beta
that's what we're talking about and
joining us now up from long beach
johanna great to see you how's
everything it's great thanks uh great to
have you with us and also jeff from
infinity ward so
we saw the first gameplay thanks for
that extended sequence looks incredible
uh jeff tell us a bit about that mission
uh where is that set in the game what
are we seeing there absolutely so um
first of all we're really excited to
welcome back uh captain john price and
uh
uh gaz uh garrick um
you know they're not they're not
actually in what we just saw today but
uh they're returning members from 141
and then the other two characters uh
that were you may recognize from the
older franchise that we're reimagining
are uh simon ghost riley and uh of
course uh soap john mctavish um and then
a couple other new characters in here
that we're really excited that we got to
create for this game
first uh commander philip graves and uh
mexican special forces uh colonel
alejandro and alejandro i guess they
were it's a character we're really
excited about he's a guy who's super
capable and a guy who's just as
important as test course
um but as far as the level is concerned
um you know this i got a shout out to iw
you know this was a tremendous
collaboration across all of the the
different uh disciplines as you saw
everybody coming together some really uh
motivated devs here and uh you know you
saw the the wind and the uh animations
and the awesome sound design and of
course our new water tech which is
actually pushing the boat in different
directions it's creating a physically
dynamic environment allowing for the
cover you were seeing in certain cases
you could be behind cover and then
suddenly that cover would shift and
leave you exposed but it also leaves the
enemy exposed creating this emergent
gameplay um so again i'm i'm very
excited just can't wait that i'm so
excited that we get to show it off today
and that's just a hint of where things
are going to go uh johnny tell us a bit
about call of duty overall modern
warfare 2 obviously you know we're so
excited that it's back this year but
you've got lots going on across quality
what can we expect from you guys this
year yeah we um first of all thanks for
having us here we're just so excited for
october 28th
it's such a big moment not just for
modern warfare 2 and everything that
jeff and the team at infinity ward have
built but it really marks the step
change what we're calling a
transformational moment for the entire
franchise you're going to see incredible
rendering incredible graphics all the
things just within the game itself built
all on one shared engine now across war
zone and modern warfare 2 going forward
of course there's a lot of chatter and
interest about the new warzone
experience we're affectionately calling
it warzone 2.0
there will be
a standalone experience of war zone for
current existing players as well so
we're going to sort of feed the entire
community there but all eyes on the 28th
and again i think the collaboration's
just been incredible everybody's so
excited for task force one for one um
warzone coming to mobile as well for
players on the go
we're on steam as you know i mean so
it's just a big moment and there's going
to be a lot more to come in the in the
months to follow well before we we leave
we gotta ask a little bit about war zone
two i know we just you know we're
showing gameplay here on this but can
you tell us anything there's a little
bit it seems like there's a little bit
of a tease maybe in the trailer
yesterday yeah when we're seeing that
from the community we love when the fans
can pick up some things um some chatter
about maybe seeing high-rise and other
elements but we will get into the
details of war zone 2.0 for sure it will
be an extension of the modern warfare 2
universe so all the more reason why we
think this game this moment is such an
important uh title for all of us looking
looking ahead and like we said we're
having a bold vision around the entire
future for the franchise so we're in
we're in position we're really excited
all right well we're looking forward to
october thanks so much for giving us a
first look at the gameplay call of duty
modern warfare 2. thanks johanna and
jeff
all right well we've got lots more
summer game fest still to go and now
it's time to announce a classic pc
gaming franchise is coming back with a
sequel over 30 years after its first
release i love this game when i was
growing up so i'm honored to share this
very first look
[Music]
[Applause]
all right let's turn back time back in
2017 we announced witchfire at the game
awards almost five years later i am so
excited the team at the astronauts in
poland has put together an in-depth look
at the gameplay of this dark fantasy
first person shooter which will enter
early access soon i am so excited to
play this and i bet you will be too
after you see this
[Music]
so
okay next up comes an ambitious new game
from a new independent studio in europe
starring some very familiar names enjoy
this world premiere new game
announcement
[Music]
officer taylor medlog
today um
i can't believe what i saw
solace
everything okay in there
[Music]
aah
something's going on here
and i need to find out what it is
that's something brand new and look who
it is
troy and roger in person guys uh this is
so fun the fact that you're working on a
game together what a cool team up uh
welcome to the show uh good to be here i
gotta ask you guys uh who are your
characters in this game
well i get to play a character named
wyatt taylor as a medical officer who's
stationed at this base fort solace
and uh it's the epicenter of this
mystery that we'll discover and uncover
as we go through the game and of course
my character will be at times in
opposition with
roger's character
the battle we've been waiting to see
everyone yeah yeah oh man we can't wait
to show you what we've been working on
and by the way jeff this looks awesome
man it's so great to be here thanks for
having us it's so great that you're in
another game we i mean it's feeling this
is your first game since you read
deadpool one of the first major ones for
a while and i play a character by the
name of jack leary he's a maintenance
engineer on a remote martian mining post
his job is to make sure that none of the
equipment breaks down while it's on
their graveyard shift the graveyard
shift meaning mars and earth are really
far apart from each other and their
orbits around the sun so help is not a
simple call away
uh i gotta ask i think a lot of people
will see this thing and they'll probably
wonder
you know it's a new team right uh you
know independent studio in europe that's
making this but with huge production
values i'm curious like how did you guys
get attached to this tell us a bit about
the background i i will say that 2020 to
me was the most impactful year for games
it was the first i mean obviously we had
this unprecedented event with the
pandemic and that forced the way that we
looked at everything as a society but
also the way this industry functioned it
was also brand new consoles we had more
tools that were being made available
that were leveling the playing field
between like the aaa studios and the
indie studios of the triple eye studios
and so just like anybody else we got
reached out uh james tinsdale with this
brand new studio said we'd like for you
to uh consider being a part of this game
and he walked me through a very brief
description of what the experience was
going to be like and
at the very beginning he said
it's we want this to feel it's a it's a
tight thriller we want it to feel like
dead space
meets uh duncan jones moon and i was
like sign me up i'm into that absolutely
and full like performance capture and
everything oh yeah absolutely new studio
brand new energy and of course i get to
work with one of the best in the
business and me i get the privilege
who's the other getting to see this guy
and watch him in action i know i love to
work and i love the challenges and all
the new innovations that this medium
provides to performers we can't wait to
show you what we've been working on i
think it's going to know i guess i've
seen some of the behind the scenes and
the performance capture unreal engine 5
i mean this is it looks absolutely
phenomenal can you give us a hint about
the the game play like what are we going
to do in this game yeah the verbs are
always important so we're going to let
the game speak for itself we'll be
showing you more later on but uh this is
a game where you as the player you're
going to be exploring you're going to be
discovering like we said it's a very
tight thriller so you're moving very
fast pace through this world you'll be
multiple locations multiple ways for you
to
traverse which we're excited to show you
about uh and then the the narrative is a
huge element to this the they they
didn't waste uh any any resources on the
the performance for sure i gotta tell
one quick story if i can um that was one
of our favorite moments um
there is a lot of action in this game
and that was at the the forefront of
this and to speak to the performance
capture aspect we brought in an
incredible i gotta give a shout out to
nathaniel our stunt coordinator who
walked us through and really approached
us in a completely different way than
anything i've ever done before and he
says i want to know the story of this
fight and so roger and i sat down we
said these are where our characters are
and he goes give me one hour and i will
come back to you with the story of this
fight and after an hour he comes to us
and he goes it was like a like a
recovery program it was 12 steps and he
walked us through this incredible
fight you know about halfway out halfway
through i started tuning him out and i
was like hey man i just want you know
i've got no ego about this but i can do
a lot of things but i i can't do this
and he grabbed me by my shoulders and he
says oh you can you will and it's going
to be glorious and we did and we did
dance it was a lot of trust and it
worked out yeah i mean we're excited
yeah i mean this is so cool to see is it
an independent studio doing this teaming
up with you guys we can't wait to see
more troy roger thanks for joining us
here happy to be here thank you all
right appreciate it very much guys all
right well next up keeping up with the
space team it's time to world premiere a
very exciting new game which will
feature a musical score by industry
legend mick gordon this one is gonna
grab you and we are so honored to debut
it
[Music]
uh
so
doesn't that look great that was routine
coming to xbox and pc it was first
announced a decade ago and is now
officially back i can't wait to see more
now it's time to check in with a very
special guest who's been in his fair
share of video games including most
recently fortnite as the foundation
dwayne johnson welcome to summer game
fest how are you
what's up everybody and what's up jeff
and what is up to the
summer game fest audiences live
streaming right now around the world and
everybody inside the epic imax theaters
dwayne johnson here coming at you from
my iron paradise the very hot
and sweaty
and smelly iron paradise uh powered by
of course zoa energy the number one
fastest growing energy drink in the game
you guys know me uh by a lot of
nicknames the rock
la roca in spanish uh uncle handsome
sexiest man alive uh big drink energy
always room for a cheesy joke there's
always room for the extra large cheese
pizza especially when i'm delivering and
i deliver them often uh
you guys also know me as the
greatest and most electrifying surprise
in gaming that happened you know me as
the foundation and i got to tell you
guys uh number one thank you so much for
the crazy response of me becoming the
foundation but also
i got to say that you know i've had such
a pleasure uh working with um epic games
and uh the teams over there and we
cannot wait to show you what we have in
store for the future and speaking of the
future in the future you will also know
me as black adam black adam as millions
of you know around the world who know
the black out of mythology he is
ruthless he is unstoppable and for those
who don't i always like to say a quick
tutorial is this
um black adam has the powers of superman
but the only difference well there's a
few differences but one of the biggest
differences is superman's weakness is
magic and black adam's one of his
superpowers is magic so you do the math
uh october 21st i cannot wait for you
guys to see black adam around the world
in theaters only and you guys will
finally see the hierarchy of power in
the dc universe change uh it has been an
honor to become black adam and it was a
it is a role that's in my dna and that i
was born to play i was born to play the
man in black and i'm honored to show it
to you guys on october 21st so until
then uh
stay healthy stay safe stay focused
keep having fun keep kicking ass
enjoy your gaming and i'll see you down
the road
this is black adam
black adam
what have your powers ever given to you
nothing but heartache
i was a slave until i died
then i was reborn a god
you can be the destroyer of this world
or you can be its savior
that's up to
you behind you
did you just catch a rocket
[Music]
one two three
uh
[Music]
great
okay
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
do what it takes
mix it all up
[Music]
that was so fun to see courage and ray
and that fall guys piece and you can
play and download fall guys for free
starting june 21st across all platforms
including nintendo switch xbox pc and
playstation all right back to another
new game announcement we're going to
announce a brand new game and universe
from a new team of legendary developers
check this out
[Music]
signals breaking up command i'll do one
last scan see you soon over
okay hurry
[Music]
um
command i
may be on to something
[Music]
i have it command repeat i have it
mission accomplished
ah
hang tight doc i've got this
so
[Music]
[Applause]
glad you could make it we gotta move
now
there's a storm coming
and hell's coming with it
there you have it tim congratulations
stormgate is real we have a name and
some details uh so first of all
congratulations on this announcement
we're so excited about the return of rts
brand new uh franchise what is a
stormgate though all right so stormgates
are portals that open during a massive
solar storm that unleash the infernal
host on future earth
okay uh and we saw some hints of some i
mean you know you guys coming from
blizzard and starcraft everyone wants to
know about races uh you know tell us
about the sides in this rts game yeah
we're unveiling our first two factions
today but there will be more uh so the
human resistance and we saw an
archaeologist from the human resistance
in that
intro cinematic and then also the
infernal hosts who are these demon-like
monsters who come from another world
i think one thing everyone wants to know
about especially your background
pedigree of the team of you know where
do you want to push the rts genre it's
something we've all loved for decades
but you know opportunity for a lot of
innovation
i know you're going to show us i think
some some hints of where you're going to
go image-wise with the actual gameplay
made in unreal engine but any sense of
what you want to do for the game play in
this game
absolutely i but the first thing i want
to say is we are very consciously trying
to stay true to what players already
love about rts
where we're really trying to push the
genre and be innovative first off
approachability
for one thing we're free to play
but no pay to win no nfts nothing like
that just to
lower that barrier to entry to get
players in but we're also really trying
to be a lot more social so you'll be
able to play the campaign cooperatively
we've got three-player open-ended co-op
and we've even got three versus three
for competitive multiplayer but of
course we've also still got one v1
competitive and as a little surprise i
think we've got some first kind of work
in progress images from the game right
yeah these are still very much still
being worked on but some shots of uh
actual assets that we're building in
unreal engine 5. wow well i i love it
2023 you said for the betas people can
sign up now get ready and i'm just so
thrilled that there is a brand new rts
franchise coming from you guys and your
background and what you did you know
blizzard and starcraft we're so excited
about this team frosh giant uh thank you
so much for giving us your announcement
today on summer game fest thank you so
much for having us here really grateful
awesome all right frost giant gate keep
an eye out for it now it's time for
another indie game announcement that i'm
excited to share with you high water
check this one out
[Music]
good morning high water dwellers high
water pirate radio keeping you in the
know without flow
alphaville authorities continue to deny
false rumors that alphaville elites are
planning to evacuate to mars true or not
the one thing we can't deny is that the
world ended on a sunny day
[Music]
no one suspected the coming dark
the wave was coming but the sky was
clear
i let it wash over
[Music]
fear
what a breathtaking trailer high water
is an adventure strategy game set in a
world ravaged by extreme climate change
now speaking of the world around us the
conflict in ukraine is not far from
anyone's mind and it's impacted the
development of games including replaced
from sad cat studios a belarusian studio
with devs from belarus and ukraine the
team had long hoped to reveal a new
trailer here today but we're
understandably unable to complete it in
time guys i just want to say we're
thinking of you and all the developers
impacted by the conflict and hope to be
able to share your work at a future show
all right our next game is an official
selection of the tribeca games festival
it's american arcadia where you play
trevor whose life is being televised
with the viewing population constantly
voting you up or down when you become
unpopular you need to start running for
your life
check this out
[Music]
picture a city where technology and
science go hand in hand with fun and
entertainment
my grandfather elijah walton had a dream
to build the city of tomorrow that dream
is now a reality and that city is
arcadia
a 43 square mile metropolis where each
and every citizen enjoys a life of
luxury and comfort
broadcast live 24 hours a day seven days
a week on every digital platform
american arcadia
control
subject on the run on camera 4025
interrupt broadcast immediately
[Music]
listen to me we can't allow trevor hills
to escape under any circumstances
trevor
trevor can you hear me
be careful and don't make a sound
[Music]
don't worry
i'm going to get you out of there
apparently we've made it to the beach
next up is a sequel we've all been
anticipating for a long time there's
trouble in paradise and watch out you
don't want to get bitten after many
years of rumors we finally get an update
on this much anticipated sequel
[Music]
um
[Applause]
[Music]
let me please
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
there you have it that was goat
simulator 3 and it's coming later this
year to the epic game store
now last year marvel and 2k announced
marvel's midnight sons a tactical rpg
from firaxis games the studio behind
x-com and civilizations heroes from the
avengers and x-men cross over with
supernatural ones like blade and ghost
rider for a battle against lilith the
mother of demons today we've got a look
at some new folks set to join the battle
[Music]
this world has no hope under your watch
surrender your pain with me
and i will make you whole once more
mother won't hurt you
[Music]
typical parker luck i'm gonna need some
backup
[Music]
so
master of puppies
counting on you again old friend
three
two
one
[Music]
that used to always work well it did
that one time
that was midnight suns and now we're
moving on to the wonderful world of
cuphead the delicious last course and
can you believe it we're only a couple
weeks away from playing the delicious
last course dlc you see how they did
that for cuphead joining me now is maya
maldenhauer from studio mdhr so first of
all maya it's really coming it's really
coming june 30th on all major platforms
we are thrilled well i'm so thrilled too
that uh i think all the fans can't
believe that this is here and i've been
lucky enough to play this actually on my
steam deck uh last week you guys gave me
a copy this
i can't people are not gonna be ready
for how amazing this looks and the
backgrounds and what you guys have done
i feel like you've you've amped up
obviously the gameplay it's difficult as
we would expect but the visual look you
guys have taken it even to the next
level i didn't think was possible yeah
we absolutely did i couldn't pinpoint
one thing that we're proud of in this
because we really honed our craft took
everything to the next level from
animation the backgrounds the music
gameplay design um and of course a new
playable character miss chalice i'm very
proud of her
chalice is fun to play as and even
though this is a dlc it feels like it's
its own game inside of cuphead in many
ways it is it is definitely yeah you
just get on the island and there you are
off to this new uh new territory which
is yeah it's our biggest island yet
super-sized bosses lots of secrets to
discover um don't let any rock go
unturned yes and lots of challenge ahead
well i know you brought i know you want
you don't want people to necessarily
have too much spoiled about the game but
you brought a little something a little
something yeah it's a brand new gameplay
footage of one of our new bosses
mortimer freeze it takes place in an icy
arena
and features some of my personal
favorite attacks and transformations we
hope everyone enjoys it all right let's
check it out cuphead the delicious last
course next week
[Music]
foreign
so
[Music]
[Applause]
now if you want even more cuphead and
who doesn't tomorrow we will show you an
exclusive look at season two of the
cuphead show when i co-host netflix's
geeked week which will include new show
and game announcements it streams at 10
a.m pacific 1 pm eastern
and that's not all there's more summer
game fest all weekend long coming up
next is the day of the devs indie
showcase with i am 8 bit and double fine
then devolvers marketing countdown to
marketing tomorrow after geeked week
there is the epic game store showcase at
11am pacific 2pm eastern with news on
rocket league and the tribeca game
showcase and sunday don't miss the xbox
and bethesda game showcase with a look
at the future of xbox and game pass
now we have some exciting news for
nintendo switch and pc fans about neon
white a game where you play an assassin
from hell who slays demons for the
chance to ascend to heaven
[Music]
we're called neons
sinners plucked from hell to do god's
dirty work
but i'm finding it hard to believe we're
in heaven
10 days
new day you mission from all mikey you
think you can win me over by showering
me with gifts uh
[Music]
we've shown you lots of games today made
by huge teams now it's time for a game
made by a single father in poland
over the past year he's brought on some
help to bring his vision for a
fast-paced action game midnight fight
express to life let's take a look
[Music]
you know the saying
get knocked down get up again that whole
spiel
well it's time partner
time to rise up
together
[Music]
it's happening
big guy's actually going through with it
while i sat at his side seeing lives as
dollar signs
had the stink of corruption all over me
you know who put it there
not him
me
well i ain't wearing it anymore and
neither are you
tonight we wash this whole damn city
down
such a cool game i'm happy to announce
that a pc demo of this game is going
live right now on steam and will be part
of the steam next fest next week i
really want more playable games to get
in the hands of you guys at home and
that's one of them check it out all
right joining me now is megan from
digital extremes to talk all things
warframe megan how you doing i'm so good
my fellow canadians i know we got like
just happen to always have these
canadian teams on the show i don't know
how that works out right okay we do well
we have a great connection we've also
done a lot with warframe over the years
and i know right now anyone watching on
twitch for more than 30 minutes this
show is going to get a special twitch
drop right that's right i already have
seen people getting it so it's very
exciting she's right there loud and
proud protea 30 minutes for watching
thank you for letting us kind of take
over your special events category but
she is there and she is for you if you
are properly linked up no warframe you
know i said we've done a lot over the
years you guys have done incredible
things with the game and i know you have
tennocon coming up in july which is your
big kind of event of the year to reveal
what's next what what can you tell us
well i can't tell too much
but yeah july 16 2022 it's a digital
event again this year
today actually we just launched the
digital items for it so you can get some
in-game goodies some really cool
cosmetics some merch all that really
great stuff went live today but of
course the reason i'm here
is to you know kind of debut we have our
tenno live during tennocon which is our
big reveal of the night and we usually
do is a little bit of a gameplay a
little bit of a demo and i think a lot
of people can suspect what it might be
but i'm here to kind of confirm what it
is that tunnel live is going to show
and what is that
can i say it yes i think you can okay
you're going to get your first look at
the diviri paradoxes finally finally i
know i know it's been a couple years uh
but davier paradox is going to be what
tenno live is all about and i'm so happy
the team worked really hard on the
teaser you're about to see for it and
i'm just really proud and excited to
show it awesome well thanks so much for
being here on summer game fest let's
take a look at that right now
[Music]
my child
my friend
what was done is done
new dangers
new choices await us now
[Music]
[Applause]
for
now dream of who we were
and of who we have become
[Music]
next it's time for a new look at hong
kai star rail an upcoming open world
space rpg yeah a lot of space today from
gentian impact studio hoya verse across
mobile and pc this studio continues to
deliver and this new trailer reveals for
the very first time a new and exotic
realm players will be able to explore
[Music]
listen
you are in a daze right now
you don't know who you are
why you're here
none of that matters
in the near future
you will encounter many perils
you will meet companions who treat you
like family
and embark on unimaginable adventures
remember what you feel in this moment
as long as you know in your heart where
you're heading
you will arrive at the end of the story
that's the you i like
[Music]
i have wine to soothe the souls of
honored guests
[Music]
welcome aboard the ciao
and that's not all from hoyoverse today
i'm excited to introduce you to zenless
zone zero their next major new ip it's a
futuristic urban action game i have to
say i'm blown away by what i've seen so
far it was announced a couple weeks ago
and it has the detail of gentian impact
with a fast-paced action style here is
the world premiere of a brand new look
at zenless's notable characters armed
enemies and world of danger
[Music]
can you
hey
all right
one of my favorite reveals last year was
tmnt shredders revenge which reminds us
all of the turtles arcade games back in
the day well it's nearing the end of
development and the team wanted to use
sgf as a way to reveal one exciting
aspect of the game they've been keeping
under wraps until now
[Music]
patrick
bye
[Music]
so
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
how far will you push humankind
humankind allows you to shape your
civilization by combining a multitude of
historical civilizations from the
ancient to the modern era
one piece is celebrating its 25th
anniversary this year and bandai namco
is bringing the mega popular franchise
back to video games with one piece
odyssey monkey to luffy and his crew of
pirates are off on their next adventure
this trailer reveals the setting a
mysterious island where luffy and his
straw hat crew become marooned in this
exciting upcoming jrpg
[Music]
the straw hat pirates journey along the
grand line
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
see hold on
sodor
filled with new encounters
and hidden mysteries
[Music]
unravel the adventure that awaits
in an odyssey beyond imagination
one-piece odyssey
this august soul hackers 2 from atlas
launches and we've got your first listen
to the english voice cast with this
quick new look
[Music]
take my hand
you get one more chance to make things
[Music]
so that's our mission then save the
world
with so many new games featured across
sgf events you might be wondering how to
plan for your summer gaming dreams nerd
wallet can help you find the smartest
credit card to reward your gaming
purchases at nerdwallet.com
the epic mega sale is going on right now
save up to 75 percent off top pc titles
with an additional 25 off eligible
products and it wouldn't be the mega
sale without the free games vault
featuring man eater be sure to claim
your copy before the sale ends on june
16th
tune in to the epic game store twitch
channel for our summer showcase on june
10th at 2 p.m eastern 11 a.m pacific
we're taking a look at new announcements
and updates from pc titles heading to
the store this year and beyond
[Applause]
you nuts
[Music]
uh
oh
[Music]
you're gonna get hit with the unexpected
in mario striker's battle league in this
no holds bark soccer-ish sport chaos
reigns supreme so prepare to do whatever
it takes to claim victories so much fun
it hurts
mario striker's battle league only on
nintendo switch game rated everyone 10
and up
[Music]
hi my name is carl and i'm a developer
and metal hell singer you know how in
some games with the music's really good
you feel compelled to move and shoot to
the beat but what if you had to in metal
the better you are at slaying to the
beat the more intense everything gets
and we have vocal performances from
legendary artists like serge thank you
from system of down so while head
banging isn't mandatory we do recommend
it our demo is live now on steam xbox
and playstation platforms so go check it
out and slay to the beat
is
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
kill me
me
[Music]
that one was metal hellsinger coming
later this year from funcom a rhythm
shooter with metal music and right now
as i mentioned a demo has launched on pc
xbox and playstation for you to play for
free
next up a new game launches tomorrow the
quarry from super massive games this
spiritual successor to until dawn stars
david arquette and an all-star cast
that's getting great reviews and this is
one of those binge-worthy teen horror
entertainment experiences where your
every choice shapes your story and
determines who lives and who dies at a
camp in upstate new york here's the
first look at the launch trailer
family is the most important thing in
the world
but if your whole family
you know like
every last one of them decided to jump
down the bottom of a well they're all
just
hanging on the end of a rope
how can one person be expected to pull
them all back out you can't
[Music]
so you pull on that rope and you're just
gonna fall right down at the bottom of
the well with the rest of them
and what's the point of that
what
there is a lot more to this than you
realize
like what
kidnapping murder cover-ups i think the
whole packet family is in on it
you have no idea what's going on here
got a goddamn clue
all right let's do this
[Music]
who should i call
you mean 9-1-1 who says 91-1
good-bye cruel world
we gotta get out
i'm gonna enjoy watching you die
this isn't a ghost story it's a creature
feature it's really happening and you're
all in it this is gonna get a little
messy
[Music]
them's the rules you noob
back at the game awards we were proud to
reveal nightingale a shared world
survival crafting game from inflection
games up in canada now it's time to give
you a brand new look and deeper look at
the game including its innovative realm
card system that lets you impact things
like the weather pattern resources and
challenges in its procedural realms
here's your exclusive new look
[Music]
you're alone in the realms i'm afraid
the portals are a
mess not even sure if nightingale made
it
given how fragile you humans are
i'd say that staying fed dry and rested
should be your priority
if the portal arch is inactive you'll
need to make round cards from rare
resources
once you have realm cards you can
activate the portal
beware though
vowel things lurk in the interrelated
void
waiting to get in
be ready with your axe pick
[Music]
if these shadows have offended
think but this
and all is mended
the saints are marching in on august
23rd with the reboot of saints row that
we revealed last year at gamescom and
today we're happy to announce the launch
of the boss factory demo across pc and
console which lets you design and set up
your character and since it's saints row
you guys are gonna have a lot of fun
with this one check it out
[Music]
guys
you gotta do something to capture
people's attention so what do we build
next
[Music]
dinner and a show baby
quicker
i want all the powers
[Music]
i want all the power
next we've got an exclusive first look
at extended gameplay of warhammer 40k
darktide fat sharks follow-up to the
critically acclaimed vermintide series
dark tide promises intense four-player
co-op action and terrifying enemy hordes
to team up against and it's our out on
september 13th for pc on steam and
exclusively on console on xbox
[Music]
manufacturing cell 1736 is heading
towards your power systems failure
thanks to a bit of heretic sabotage
so you're gonna restore the colon and
hopefully save the day
[Music]
again
access the operations array and use the
cryonic rods to flush the system
preferably before something explodes
head on through the ventilation tunnels
and look for an access point
this way move it
[Applause]
oh
where they're needed
and put those cryonic rods to work
[Applause]
look for a way out
[Music]
bluebird team is known for psychological
horror games like blair witch and the
medium today they are ready to reveal
their latest creation made completely in
unreal engine 5 for a visceral horror
experience it's a return to the world of
layers of fears get a dose
of this
[Music]
someone once said insanity runs in our
family
let it
run
they say it's a tale of sadness and
guilt
of an artist
trapped in a place beyond redemption
it's a lie
this is a story of my fear being an
hatred of the horror of my loneliness
and it is mine
to tell
now i see it
all this misery
all this suffering
there was no other way
you really
shouldn't
have
an empty shell
cannot live forever
[Music]
by this body
now
i break free
this october gotham nights arrives
batman is dead and it's up to the batman
family batgirl nightwing red hood and
robin to protect gotham to give us an
exclusive new look let's head to
montreal to hear from executive producer
fleur marty
[Music]
hello and warm welcome from wb games
montreal i'm fla marti i'm the executive
producer on gotham nights
today we are thrilled to share more with
you on one of our beloved nights
nightwing
this showcase is the first in our
character series and we're really
looking forward to share more with you
as we continue working towards our
launch on october 25th
so i hope you enjoy the show and stay
tuned
i had nothing
and then this city became my home
its people became my family
gotham gave me everything
it deserves to feel safe
[Music]
no matter how hard we try
there's always more to do
and now
it's up to me
[Music]
i got this bruce
that was gotham knights and now we
welcome oh look who it is neil druckmann
from naughty dog
co-president of naughty dog uh great to
have you with us neil it's been a uh an
eventful day on the internet for naughty
dog fans and uh i think we jinxed
ourselves we were joking about last
night like watch the assets will leak
and yes lo and behold that's what
happened well the good news is there's
some stuff that hasn't leaked that we
have lots to share with people about all
things at naughty dog but first of all
it is a you know it's a big month
actually for last of us fans because uh
last of us one and two both launched in
june and it's nearing its two-year
anniversary for last of us uh part two
which is hard to hard to believe
yeah it's crazy uh um you know nine
years for last of us one two years for
last was part two and we still hear from
fans they're still sending us letters
and art and these characters in this
journey and this world mean so much to
them
um
and it's it's just been kind of amazing
like last was part two early this year
passed a pretty big milestone it sold
over 10 million units and that kind of
support that kind of success we're so
grateful to our fans it has allowed us
to grow as a studio and now we can take
on multiple projects more than we've
ever had at the same time
multiple projects okay very interesting
so uh what can lassa's last of us fans
expect in the future from you thank you
for asking jeff uh so one of the things
we've mentioned a while back is what
started out as a multiplayer mode has
evolved due to the team's ambition they
really wanted to do something beyond
what we've ever done before at naughty
dog and we felt the way to do it justice
is to make it a standalone title and
over the they've been working on it for
the past two years ambition has grown
and we're not quite ready to fully
unveil it but we're ready to lift the
current a little bit and just give you
like an update of where we're at
okay well uh what can you tell us about
this new stand-alone multiplayer game
yeah so uh we have a concept art that we
want to show
but what i can tell you oh
is that this game is big okay um it's as
big as any of our single player games
that we've done and in some ways bigger
it's got a story um the way we're
telling that story is very unique to
this game um it's got a brand new cast
of characters it takes place at another
place another part of the united states
like a city might somewhat familiar some
people i'm sure our fans have already
figured it out um
uh and it's it's it's really cool and
it's being headed by venus agarwal
anthony newman and uh joe pandnati all
veterans of uncharted and last of us and
you're going to see a lot more of this
game come next year
next year so i wait till next year to
hear more about that one okay well very
exciting that this has evolved and i
mean that concept art looks incredible i
can't wait to see naughty dog
storytelling fused with multiplayer live
game uh it's it's something special we
can't wait to show it either okay well
um that's not all we also have something
that i've been reading about on the
internet every day it feels like up in
calgary they're filming the last of us
show for hbo right
yeah so uh for the past year um you know
we've teamed up with craig mason of
chernobyl fame and hbo to adapt the last
of us into a tv uh tv show um they've
been filming and uh
it's pretty incredible the stuff i'm
getting back when we're looking at back
at naughty dog we can't help but feel
emotional because not only is it so good
and the quality is so high it's so
authentic to what we've made in the game
um and
uh i i just can't i couldn't be proud of
like again craig and that whole crew and
everybody that's up there uh and they're
actually their last day of filming is
tomorrow so the entire series last day
of filming
filming us tomorrow craig is up there
right now kind of wrapping it all up uh
so it's it's pretty close it's closer
than you might think and you actually
got to direct one of the episodes
yes uh i think that really speaks to the
kind of collaboration and trust that
exists between naughty dog and hbo they
invited me to direct one of the episodes
um i think we have an image from the
episode that actually directed oh okay
we could first look let's take
so you can see uh this is a certain
museum that players might know from the
game um and i really have to talk about
pedro pascal and bella ramsey and not
only directing them but seeing them do
all the other episodes they've thrown
themselves at these roles um for a whole
year
watching the nuance that they bring to
these characters their relationship on
and off camera i couldn't help but think
about troy baker and ashley johnson it
felt so similar to the chemistry those
two actors had when we made the game
and it really feels like this is going
to be
something special and i will say this
will be the most authentic video game
adaptation yet well i mean that first
image that they put out it just i mean
it feels like the video game everything
that i've seen both public and other
stuff makes it feel sort of super
legitimate you said and that's awesome
to see uh joel and ellie from from the
front side now for the first time um so
we'll see more of that next year that's
coming as well right serious uh you'll
hear about it very soon that's okay i'll
say right now all right well last of us
hbo very very exciting uh and i hear you
actually have a couple actors from the
show who are uh gonna join us you happen
to have a couple actors here that are
part of the show we should bring them up
okay come on up
oh what's up guys hello
surprise troy's back again hello
good to see you uh i'm a little confused
though i thought maybe pedro bella but
troy ashley out here uh from the game
right so uh when craig and i started
working on the show almost one of our
very first meetings we said troy and
ashley have to be a part of it um and
we're such fans of like the talent and
the help like helping us create joel and
ellie um we felt like it was so
important that they become part of the
show and it wasn't
it has to be more than just like kind of
like a wink to the camera and like a
cameo yeah these are real roles that
we're keeping on the wraps for now
uh but man i was i'm bummed that i
couldn't be there with you guys when you
filmed your stuff there's been so much
stuff so
so good on the internet there's so much
like talk about what's being filmed and
i think that's you guys have kept a
complete secret that you so you were up
there and you filmed your roles by now
obviously well keeping secrets with this
franchise is kind of old hat like we've
had for today
except for the date
uh it was it was one of the hardest
things for us to do is to let not let
people know that because we're so proud
of it and the work that we did we worked
hard the crew i have to say um when i
walked out on set
um
to be met with literally every person
that i met on that crew
uh is such a fan of this game and they
all knew what it was that they were
working on and committed to working on
this project because of their fan and
their love for the for the game uh was
one of the greatest it was like i was
coming home
to friends
yeah i i the attention to detail
the crew was amazing bella and pedro are
man
i
they're so perfect and it it we've been
trying to sort of describe that feeling
of sort of seeing them in person
it's it's like
it's like the characters coming to life
but it
it's so much more than that i feel like
i can't fully explain it but i am
so excited to be a part of it and just
i can't wait to see it i think it is
going to be
so good
it's it's i love the story i love
the part i'm so excited about the series
and the fact that you guys are gonna be
in it and undisclosed roles i'm so
fascinated how it's gonna sort of
bob and weaving and you know are these
characters we know from the game that
they're playing new characters can you
tell us anything
yes
i can tell you so sneaky all right well
we're so excited maybe it's already on
twitter right now
hey all right well
let's talk about what was on twitter
earlier uh today lots of talk about uh
the idea or really what's happening is
it looks like you guys are remaking the
original game and this is like a
ground-up remake is that right that's
right uh we wanted to give people the
definitive version of the first game
that wasn't encumbered by any technology
i wanted to find a way to get even
closer to our original vision and we're
able to do it on the ps5
and pc and instead of talk about it
let's look at it all right let's take a
look at the last of us part one
so why'd you leave boston
i've been on quite the adventure little
brother
i reckon it's got something to do with
that girl
he's got everything to do with that
little girl
[Music]
you know i've never been this close
to the outside
so is that everything you hoped for
can't be any worse out there
can it
[Applause]
once upon a time i had somebody that i
cared about
and in this world that's good for one
thing
get you killed
i can take care of myself how many close
calls have we had
i get in trouble down there you make
every
shot
count
i got this
hope you know how to use that thing
i've had some practice
truly one of my favorite games of the
past decade guys what's your reaction to
that yeah we haven't seen that yet yeah
you're watching it in real time yeah
uh
it's because you did these perfect these
performances you did a decade ago yeah
you didn't go back in i mean you used
the original performances yeah actually
we came up with a process we could take
the original uh animation that we did
for the faces and kind of like retarget
it on these new rigs that have a lot
more fidelity and then the animators
went back and forth side by sides here
just how much it has changed that you
went and you redid the models and we
built everything everything was rebuilt
from the ground up uh same art director
re-art directed the whole thing from the
ground up
but the the great thing about these
faces is that um they're closer to their
original performance all the animators
went and studied those videos and got it
closer to what you did on set than we
could have achieved before um and that's
just like one of the things and we could
talk about like this brand new ai like
all the combat is redone um
just uh the fidelity of everything 60
frames per second all the stuff you're
getting on the ps5 again we wanted to
give knowing because of the show because
this they're all all new players for ps5
and pc yeah we wanted them to have the
definitive version of the last of us
amazing well now you guys get to reply i
mean when was the last time you guys
played the game
i i actually played it again just to
refresh my memory before working on the
show um
i was a just a glutton for punishment
and i went straight from playing uh
never playing straight into part two
um and so the last time i played
literally would have been two years ago
since we're celebrating the anniversary
of part two coming out so i mean it
looks like i'm definitely going to be up
for another playthrough
yeah i can't wait to go back because i
can't you guys do such an amazing job on
that original game and it's it's really
when you play it when you see it in
motion it's really night and day from
what it used to be i imagine that you
know think of the last of us two combat
but kind of that back in the last of us
once it's the whole like all the new
animation system the new ai system
everything we've learned on like
untreaded four last of us two we applied
to this again to give that definitive
version just to give a quick shout out
uh this project is headed up by matthew
gallant and shauna skye
uh and you'll hear a lot more about and
see a lot more about over the coming
weeks leading up to the release
september 2nd on ps5 all right and
shortly thereafter on pc we will look
forward tonight neil you've talked a lot
about
games directed by other people what what
are you directing you still making games
still making games i haven't given up my
my day job
uh it's a little early to talk about it
maybe if someone in places wants to leak
it then we can talk about it now uh
otherwise uh we'll say but you do have a
new project do you have a new project uh
but we'll save it for another summer
game fest okay
okay well we'll see we'll try and save
it all right troy ashley neal thank you
so much for dropping by summer game fest
and i am so excited that the last of us
is returning as you said in september so
thanks guys appreciate it thanks jeff
awesome
all right well that is gonna do it
thanks to naughty dog and playstation
for that very special uh look at the
last of us and the entire franchise
where things are going um very very
excited about that all right summer game
fest continues over the next few days
coming up right now on this very stream
is day of the des with i am 8bit and
double fine including an exclusive new
look at the planet atlanta and then the
devolver digital showcase tomorrow we've
got netflix geeked week which i'll be
co-hosting and the tribeca game showcase
streaming along with the epic game store
showcase and then finally sunday it's
the xbox and bethesda game showcase you
can stream them all at
summergamefest.com as for me i'll see
you again in august when we are back
live in cologne germany for gamescom
opening night live on august 23rd and
then the game awards will return in
december live from the microsoft theater
in los angeles and finally i'm excited
to share that summer game fest will
return in june 2023 as a digital and
in-person event to bring the gaming
community together thanks for being a
part of summer game fast and remember
there are more events and announcements
to come we'll see you soon
[Music]
and we're back welcome to gamespot's
coverage of summer game fest 2022. jeff
keely thank you for handing it back she
must know he's not officially handing it
back off to us but it felt like it those
shoes
anyways we saw so much i'm there's a lot
to be excited about a few things i'm
just just gonna say callisto protocol
i went in there with a slight sense of
just be like i need to see more yeah
i saw more
i'm still shaking about it shake with
excitement i'm joined with devante
chisholm
hello came in from new jersey to join us
in san francisco but he's we're not
alone because i'm on the field we have
lucy james and some more hussein welcome
back folks
how's the energy how you feeling tam
you know i drank a coffee and then
chugged a bottle of water i desperately
need to piss but let's see how this goes
just do it just
go for it
right now i'm surrounded world premiere
one two three four five people i don't
think i can sneak a piss into the ball
around these people lucy how you doing
how's your bladder
i peed in the middle of it i was like i
think it was during humankind i'm sorry
but i was like i think this is my moment
but it was great it was a fun show i'm
sad i'm sad obviously that the last of
us
leaked um and that was the close-up
that's really a good
we still had like we still the
multiplayer we still had like we still
had a glimmer of things that we didn't
know was coming at least i didn't know
it was coming yeah but we'll get into it
first off i just want to say
jeff keely you sneaky sneaky dude you
were like temp your expectations
we're only going to see stuff that has
been previously announced and all of a
sudden like right out of the gate he was
like hey here's something you've never
seen before world peace world premiere
premiere
so
i was i gotta say there was a lot aliens
dark descent that was the first big kind
of like out of nowhere premiere we've
had a lot of aliens games over the years
it never seems to stop but this one's
coming from focus who you mentioned
earlier for plaguetail yeah which uh
to to go into
the the showcase and be thinking okay
playtale that's that's what focus is
here for and then to get
that instead was kind of like oh man but
it's okay it's all right
we've had so many temps and so many
different faces for aliens games um and
we didn't really get an idea of why this
was an isometric kind of four-player
shooter thing thought it would be over
the shoulder it was very surprising to
see it up in the air not this time but
i'm gonna go around the room we're gonna
just kick it off
um i just i i think i'm gonna just start
it because i already i already have it
yeah kind of
shivering in my spine go for it it was a
horror show just go ahead and talk about
it all the time
that's that's that's the one thing i
want to talk about
it is a time to be a horror fan we
talked a little bit about the pre-show
uh it's also a time to be a
sci-fi horror fan
not a bit of that but
it's a time to be a fan of dead space
like games yeah it's it's a fan last
year we had loop games we had left for
dead games
now we have death space games
is the dead space season everyone dead
space season what happened
what was what was what where was the sea
planet that all of a sudden you know a
few years in development everyone's like
oh i got an idea let's do something yeah
i mean like as with everything
no one tries something until one person
doesn't then everyone's doing it at the
same time it turns out um most of these
games have probably been in development
for years and it just so happens that
you know when when they start showing up
is the exact same time everyone else
starts showing up um with their dead
space likes
everyone's got a theme every year has
got a theme yeah lucy talk to me how do
you feel about that uh about a more gory
or is it cake or is it gore look it's
clustered is it cake oh god i mean as
someone who watched the entire
is a cake on netflix um i was
i don't know a little bit confused as to
why they showed the same trailer from
last week but i get that they added you
know an extra goal like a man getting
his face cut off very good i really
enjoyed the look at gameplay
it's
it's very funny that they are just like
oh yeah it's kind of you know we're
gonna have this gun and you can pick up
the enemies and throw them and i'm sick
you can you know you can
it's from dead space it's i mean even
the back of the neck thing like
obviously isaac had the um
the health bar on his back and so
they've just like
they flipped it and just put it on the
back of his neck um
stopping on enemies getting items like
pop animation looks so in a floating hud
can we talk about just getting um that
guy like losing his arm
and just like
getting sucked into some kind of piece
of machinery that was so great i mean
like we were we were sat in this room
and we were all watching it on the big
tv and i think i made a sound that was
like
so you know that's where i'm at there's
a dead space one like um
it has such an emphasis on when you die
it's it's a spectacle you're to sit
there and watch
it's
like it's like kind of like one for
certain games like oh my god i get it
i'm dead but there's such a they go all
in i'm trying to make it as brutal and
as and as almost like cartoonish and
over the top as possible i'm gonna be
just throwing myself in all sorts of
danger
but i gotta say like like i was i was
kind of having this conversation and i
don't know if i'm alone but it's like
you know we have
we have dead space remake coming we have
callisto protocol which is the stead
space spiritual successor and of course
i had this kind of skepticism of are we
just going to get a cover band
version of dead space are we just going
to be like hey remember that that thing
you love that you haven't had in a few
years well you're getting it full force
like
just not called that space it's called
cliffs
and the thing but watching this trailer
no matter what no matter what amount of
skepticism it might have it might be
like yeah we're getting more of it
i felt it i was like i was like squaring
in my seat i was getting excited it's
been a while it's like now is the time
for it tam how do you feel about it
yeah the concern always is like with
these trends where everyone does the
cover cover act and no one does anything
different i think what we need most is
if there are going to be a bunch of
developers doing the same kind of uh
dead space style thing we need at least
one of them to try something different
that will push it forward a bit
it's hard to say what that game
currently is callisto protocol um i mean
it looks like it's it's trying to stick
pretty close to dead space but there
might be some stuff that is in there
that we just don't know about we just
need one of these games to to provide
something fresh and exciting and
hopefully that'll be the game that
really distinguishes itself and will
define the genre or push that genre
forward the worst case scenario of all
this is a bunch of dead space and likes
come out and they're all just dead space
alikes which will be fine but very
forgettable we need one of them to kind
of step push that genre forward and in
doing so hopefully prove that there's
more life into it so people don't just
see the dead space style you know over
the shoulder style action game just as a
temporary cash in opportunity for people
who are feeling nostalgic for dead space
i know that as fans we want to we want
more of this kind of stuff and we want
people to take it in new directions and
the only way that's going to happen is
if people you know try and do more than
just make a dead space game and if
whether they do that or not remains to
be seen but i've got my fingers crossed
callisto product the very least looks
great um just hoping that they they have
a little more than just a a kind of a
cover act
yeah i think that like kind of last
statement on that before we move on to
something else is that um
it's interesting because dead space one
kind of came out at a time when survival
horror was already gone
yeah you know it's like resident evil 4
you know
as beloved as it is for a lot of people
uh even those who love it or like this
wasn't really a survival horror this
wasn't the survival horror we were you
know this is much more action-oriented
this is much more uh like narrow in that
focus
and since then you know it's like then
dead space came out a few years after
that was kind of like the last hurrah
and kind of combining those like this
action-centric but still extremely
terrifying kind of survival horror style
stuff so i'm interested to see what
cholesterol uh
that because it does not roll off the
tongue for me callisto protocol i'm
interested to see what it has uh
what appears to be kind of a little
renaissance
for the horror genre
but next thing we saw i want to throw
this over to devonte because he was the
one who was excited about it we got a
big old look at a new call of duty
modern warfare 2.
first mission yeah spew tell me about it
the the thing is with with call of duty
showing levels in this way um when we
when we get like an e3 or showcase or
anything like that
it always looks great
you know it's shiny it's it's like oh
wow explosions and like
it's fine
but it never really does anything for me
you know it's surprising even exactly
like even though i'm excited for the
game
um it's just
i want i want hands on it you know i
want to see multiplayer as well i knew
we wouldn't get that today i knew it was
just going to be story based um
but yeah it it looks great though as a
new version though
it's the interesting thing is that it
looks it's modern warfare 2 but it looks
like a remake of crew expendable the
mission from modern warfare 1 yeah which
is very confusing i mean like at points
it looks like a shelf a short remake of
crew expendable so it's it seems like
this game is going to be a remix of of
both modern warfare
2 and new things
and at some point you're like
you you have any more new ideas
what's going on uh but like the at the
end of the day like people
love
this kind of stuff like they love the
classic modern warfare stuff and
um
the vibes for most of these set pieces
are always the same so i think even if
they continue to just remix and
reshuffle their old ideas most people
would be like yep it's great it's
popcorn flick we'll just carry on
playing this shooting gallery and and be
happy with it which is like great more
power to you um
i'm hoping that there's a little more in
the rest of the game though
i don't want to jump back but you know
we saw like fort solace too kind of
going back i mean like this i feel like
the theme was sci-fi [__] i mean of
course it's like we had uh uh the reveal
of aliens dark descent which is like you
know that's the alien's just goes just
never kind of leaving so it doesn't seem
to never go away and i'm not and i'm
okay with that not that i've played a
lot i don't know like we haven't really
had a good we haven't had a good alien
game since isolation and i would argue
that alien isolation was twice as long
as it needed to be like right there
hasn't been a game
like
in a long time that's really captured
the spirit as and being you know like
the complete package and so obviously we
had fire team
colonial marines
it's and so actually when i saw the
trailer for doctor center i was like oh
please don't be alien please don't be
angry
it's like
it's i find it it's like
um i'm probably coming at this from a
very narrow scope because i like i'm a
big aliens fan but i don't play the
games yeah like i played isolation but
the isolation's up my horror alley like
that makes sense so when i saw this i
was like there's it's just like hey
alien fans out there who play these
games you got another one coming i'm so
excited for you guys
i don't know like i mean
that predator game like
i don't know what i mean they didn't
kind of do the alien one
but you know i i don't know like i'm
reserving judgment obviously it's a very
different take it has that kind of
isometric bait and switch so i'm still
very intrigued by it i've just been hurt
so many times by
people like the alien this trailer
didn't really show us anything it was it
was it was a cgi trailer and we had a
very quick glimmer at the end which is
what as i was like writing notes on it i
was like wait i was like what did i just
miss like i feel like i missed like two
seconds very quick isometric shooter
yeah so but i mean going off of that
next up it's like for salas or solace
solas solace solace
roger clark charming as always troy
baker on stage
um
like we really didn't get to see much of
that it looked more like an explorer ex
explorer base they they noted duncan
jones's moon um as an example of
inspiration was it which is a film i
love yeah so i think that's a really
interesting take on kind of having um
maybe it being isolation horror and
we've had tons of uh um i mean space is
terrifying being alone space is
terrifying but i can't really i don't i
don't trust people who say that they
want to go into space
because
why would you want to do that
uh but it looks like ford's house could
maybe be leading and especially
specifically uh noting duncan jones moon
as inspiration i was like if it is
isolation horror like i don't like i
don't know if i can really recall like a
very specific thing where like
at least off the top of my head i could
you know just be slipping at my old age
right now um leaning into just what it's
like to be by yourself
um
in a in a space in a space base
um no i guess not i mean
yeah
i guess you're right about that yeah and
then going off of that we had um
what was the other space horror game
with the mick gordon that was a big
selling point a routine
yeah but like they said it was like with
the music of mick gordon well that was
pretty much a music free trailer yeah i
was just like i was like looked over i
was like it's pretty amazing that just
like they're selling points just like
here's a new game with a soundtrack by
mick gordon not not who made it yeah
not what it's about jordan here's the
sound dragon yeah and that actually
looked kind of cool too it was just you
just had a lot of sci-fi horror i liked
that when
was announced a decade ago yeah jesus
was it yeah i don't know look cool
though i was into it i was i was a wee
lad
i don't know what i was paying attention
to a decade i was still a baby so i
don't know
all right let's go over what we were
most excited to see or the things that
got us most pumped up we went over we
went over modern warfare 2. yeah devonte
happy for you although you seem you're
like i gotta play it yeah you know but
i'm i'm happy we're getting to see it
and stuff and it's it's on the way so
cool tam uh you didn't get um eleanor
dlc
no sorry i didn't sadly that was uh a
shame but you got to look at midnight's
suns
and i did get lucky midnight suns and it
looks cool um severe lack of morbius in
there
you'd think that that would be a dead
give right now in the year of morbin um
but like you know maybe he'll get
introduced as dlc uh they showed off
spider-man um which is great uh and yeah
i'm still kind of i think it's one of
those games that looks is looking great
but i really want to play it because
the loop is what is going to really
really like sell whether that game is
good or not you know um being able to
just look at certain things and yes the
characters are there and it looks nice
and shiny and there's clearly some sort
of focus on narrative but ultimately
when you played xcom none of that was i
mean the gameplay was a big part of it
but it was that loop of doing a mission
going back to your base building the
base a bit more interacting with
soldiers giving them new names attaching
personalities to them and then sending
them out and hoping that they survive
and that kind of stuff so i think i'm
more interested in seeing more of the
loop fundamentally i think it looks cool
and and that will go a long way
especially for a superhero game um i
love the stuff that they were showing
off with like venom um and and all the
other characters so yeah it's so far so
good for for um this game got the right
behind the scenes yeah it's got the
right tone it's got a darker tone and
that's definitely what's just
distinguishing it in a lot of ways
there's not many
like supernatural parts of the marvel
universe explored anywhere you know the
mcu is just kind of getting into it now
with doctor strange and scarlet witch
and that kind of stuff um and and but
like in terms of the the game sphere
there's not much to it um traditionally
that stuff has been most represented in
the ultimate alliance games and um even
then it's not been like overtly the dark
side of of uh the supernatural side of
marvel so this is the first time we're
really getting a whole big heap a big
helping of it so i'm excited for that
i'll tell you the thing that i was
probably most excited but first off i
just kind of want to talk about we
haven't even had a chance it's like what
do we think it's like it was it was it
was it was a keely show it was like what
felt like
what keeley shows up and does
uh for summer great fest last year and
pretty much what he does for game awards
where it's just like
non-stop one thing after the other some
stuff we know some stuff we don't then
we had the rock that was the only point
where it felt like
we we like just hit the brakes really
hard
we didn't know that we were going to
work he felt ready
he looked like he'd
been you know someone found his cameo
profile and like
the thing the thing you say about the
rock right like he's a professional he's
he does this day in and day out but it
was like
i'm just gonna be in my gym shirtless
and i'm gonna hit every single talking
point in one take and it feels like it
was one take and like i'm you know super
stoked for jeff for getting like such a
big get in terms of like he's one of the
most bankable and recognizable stars in
the world but it just didn't feel
authentic like it just felt like he was
told okay you gotta hit them and stuff
you gotta hit on your drink you gotta do
your
black adam stuff and then it was like
black adam fortnite focus
at least he didn't start wrapping his
song that's that actually that probably
would have made it
but then he told me to enjoy my gaming
so
i don't care
what i really miss is that you know this
was uh
this was being shown at imax i really
feel like i missed on an opportunity oh
apparently the imax version
stopped working so everyone was watching
on their phone
before absolutely as david intended
at some point during the the uh stream
it just caught
um i think having just having just been
in an imax the first time in a long time
recently to see maverick
i that's that screen is insulting
a it's aggressive so i can only have
imagined i mean the screen is insulting
it's like it is a testament to arrogant
theaters
it's been a while for me
it was like you know constant free fall
look at that thing um
but i can only imagine what it must have
been like
with the rock yeah the rock like this
this close up
um
veins bulging shoulders he had a giant
chain behind him we're not talking i
mean
stay focused
play your game enjoy your gaming drink
water
um
but how do we feel uh defuncted how did
you feel this is your like you know
for me um
you know i did i did go into it kind of
tempering my expectations um i wasn't
expecting anything too explosive
uh
so and and with the last of us leaking
you know and not being the explosive one
last thing
right we did
but only concept art it sounds like
something it's still something right
behind me but uh this is this could be
like it's not the concept art but this
could be like you could be here
i mean like i i secretly love it when
you know they do when watch dogs does
the thing you kind of go around and you
can find places that you know and so i'm
excited to do that but i agree with you
devante it wasn't like it was such a
shame that that leaked i knew and you
know they they had a couple pieces of
concept art and nothing beyond the
trailer that we'd already seen so
and then stuff from the show too it was
nice to yeah see that but overall it's
like i it was it was a decent show you
know i enjoyed myself even if i'm not a
horror fan and it just kind of felt like
space horse
you know exactly i was just vibing off
of of you and and
although i did get the p during some of
the anime stuff sorry folks but it's
okay because jean-luc was here uh and he
was vibing off of the anime stuff so it
was like i had something also shout out
to jean luke
he's the he's the king he's the king
he's the voice behind john 100 all right
you don't see him but to the viewers out
there who are tuning in watching summer
game fest content through game spot
big shout out to jean luke seipke yeah
who's keeping us all together he's over
there in the corner send him love on
twitter speaking of which there's also
dave the dez which is uh happening right
now kicked right off after summer game
fest so we're gonna sit here and talk
for a little bit more about everything
that's happening but just want to let
you know we're also streaming that if
that's the thing you want to go see i
love day of the devs i'm looking forward
to seeing what we're doing and uh
devonte and i are going to return after
that's over as well to talk over some of
that jazz lucy how'd you feel uh this is
the first first off let me ask a bit of
a big old question oh first year of no
e3
yeah
i mean i guess it was like 2020 which
was sort of
a fake one i don't know it's like i've
been to eight in person e3s i was
obviously missed doing it from home like
you don't get the same rush and so being
here in la is really amazing like we
have a bunch of appointments for games
that we have uh seen in that showcase
and so i'm very excited to see more of
and just i don't know bask in the
excitement and i think yeah i think that
was a good showcase i totally get like i
said in the pre-show you know jeff was
tempering expectations but i think the
first half in particular was really
really strong
i am a sucker for
space related horror games so i felt
like it was very catered to me
um but it kind of had a little bit of
everything i think the cuphead thing uh
the the delicious last course the
cuphead uh kind of sneak peek of
gameplay was also another big thing
just because it's been
so long it's finally happening yes it's
a couple weeks away but it is still
really nice for it to get a big uh
position in the showcase and i i thought
it was a great showcase i i mean
it's the the world is changing e3 is
different now everyone has adapted but
the fact that we still have this like
central showcase this centralized week
where everyone tunes in and checks out
what's coming i think is still very
important i think it's still very
exciting and that's that's the thing
right it's like this is day one
we have we have we still have xbox
uh for sunday
big things yes i mean we have basically
like what two showcases from xbox coming
yeah that's a lot to look forward to
which is says a lot i mean what was the
we got warhammer 40k dark tie which was
announced as an exclusive console
exclusive for xbox which looks very
interesting like kind of cool yeah kind
of cool i haven't been paying attention
to it but yeah
it looked dark it looked metal
tam you've been you've you're you're a
veteran uh yeah i i think it's a really
interesting spot as lucy mentioned e3 is
changing but has changed but
interestingly it's e3 is now slowly
going back to what it used to be and
this kind of like a arms race a foot to
see who's going to control that you know
at the end of this show keeley did say
games for summer game fest is going to
be back um
you know again both digital and in
person and that comes off you know uh
the the kind of esa um saying that uh e3
is going to be back next year um and
keeley said that is his aim is to bring
the gaming community together which
definitely sounds like a bigger um uh
kind of e3 like experience than
he's done before and that we've got this
year so the the kind of competition is
definitely a four and kind of looking at
that i think this um
uh show served dual purpose it kind of
it is a show but it also is kind of like
table setting for what's going to come
in the future um and it's it's hard to
look at this show in isolation knowing
that's kind of part of the goal because
you have to kind of step back and look
at what jeff has put together uh broadly
speaking in the time of the great fall
of the esa and e3 um looking at this
event alone perhaps it's not the most
exciting thing i personally think that
is still solid he did a good job of
coming out and saying temper
expectations and i think that went a
long way because the stuff that we saw
is great um obviously there were a lot
of expectations for bigger things but i
think ending on last of us is a big deal
um and then also you have to look at
other things that he's done like opening
night live at gamescom and then also um
the game awards and right now the man's
got a swiss army knife of all the
biggest you know shows in in the gaming
industry and that is going to serve him
incredibly well as we go into
the next year
along with this uh to kind of stamp kind
of claim the territory of
him and owning e3 so as he scales up his
next attempt at e3 people are going to
remember stuff like this where it might
not be mind-blowing but they're not just
going to think of this they're going to
think of elden ring they're going to
think of all the other times that he's
delivered on things and promised things
and that is going to be a kind of a
really really strong position to come
back from i also think that he doesn't
he has a lot of the trust and the last
time we had an e3 um the kind of demise
of it was a breach of trust in a major
way with the doxing that was happening
and and a lot of the other things that
went on around the esa um so it's it if
looking specifically at this show i
think it was great it was good um
looking at the broader context of shows
about games in this period i think it's
a very very strong addition to
the kind of things that jeff has already
put together and puts him in a really
great position for taking over this kind
of like summer game um mess i guess
look i had i mean it's one of those
things where like
i thought it was i sincerely i thought
it was fantastic like we had the ability
like
even if we want to look at the scope of
announcements we've had outside of
summer games fest today specifically
uh you know like playstation kind of
kicked it off with state of play just
what last week yeah um with of course
big resident evil survival horror news
but also street fighter 6 and a lot of
other great things and that just kind of
segue right into a lot of like into like
what summer game fest represents is to
me which is this like celebration of
things we all love that's like coming
all at once even if it is a now even if
it is announced today or not you didn't
get the world premiere you want it or
not and like i have a lot of
appreciation for coming up to something
like this and like you see games
uh like midnight fight express and neon
white like
back to back with you know stuff like
cluster protocol and last of us remake
and it's things like that where like i
can't help and i also am just a sucker
for new things i love to see new things
even if i don't get to have that like
nerdy surgeons that we all want from
seeing something that like we're highly
anticipating but like it's stuff like
that like gives me like so many people
are like oh okay like
where the big games at we're all the big
games like dude there are so many games
coming out constantly like we are always
so busy all of us in this industry
collectively like they're so like we're
eating well with a lot of stuff but i
think jeff keeley's show i think summer
game fest specifically did a really good
job today
showing a broad spectrum of things for a
lot of different people to be excited
about yeah um i do want us to know on
one thing
blooper team
not sound hill what do you know layers
of fear
no layers of layers of fears layers of
fears you peel one onion one
layer of onion you get another bad layer
this is layers of fears no no no silent
hill no silks songs it's fine we're
gonna watch devonte play layers of
fusion
he already signed himself up
do i gotta play the other ones
yeah
all at once all i want
all three of them at the same time
all right i'm down but we didn't do it
but we didn't get overdosed
i feel like you know it's we didn't get
kojima
no i know wait does it i mean if he's
still if he's here at all has he got a
new best friend probably i mean
there was those rumors that he was all
uh more than rumors supported room is
that he was working closely with xbox so
there's still a chance oh
i was gonna say where's jeff grubb when
you need him
so he'll come out at the xbox show and
then bring keely out with him
and then that's when they'll
uh i mean i think keeley will come out
during the xbox show and unzip and it's
kojima underneath
that'd be great i was like unzip one
keep going
[Laughter]
uh kojima's coming to fortnite
you didn't hear that here um
it's but it's not just kojima it's like
the same setup as banjo-kazooie in in
uh smash brothers where it's kojima and
he's wearing a backpack and in that
backpack is jeff keeley and they fight
together
but for the most part you know he
followed through i am looking at the
list of everything he said he was going
to announce we saw it um we'll have to
wait
see a little bit more of the hbo last of
us see what the multiplayer stand alone
is by the way i didn't mention that
earlier did they did i missed this do
they mention whether or not multiplayer
is coming back to the last of us part
one
oh i don't know
yeah i would think not because i have an
entirely new multiple player game it
would be cannibalizing their own oh they
would be mostly the most incredible
shooting yourself in the leg moment
um also there was a really great moment
i was just talking about great moments
not just the rock's pecks
um
but when uh
the
not dead island 2 trailer started oh my
god
sitting next to us the voice of god that
we mentioned earlier who did this all
together he was like oh they're doing it
they're remaking the trailer and i was
like i fell for it too i was like but it
said coffee stain i was like i think
it's i don't think
he can do it
no i was like i saw coffee stain i was
like i know the dead island too has been
shopped around a bunch of developers
like it was jaeger it's uh i think sumo
for a bit i was like i don't even know
who's making this game anymore maybe it
is coffee stain
good for them stranger things have
happened uh but no what a bait and
switch i loved it that was great i would
consider that highlight right next right
next to the rock it was a big rock
those are the two highlights for you the
rock and
go i had a great time i sincerely was
like i watched this entire thing and i
was like there's something or at least i
could say i don't know i was just like
there's something
like if you walked away from this and
you at least didn't see like one thing
you're like that looked interesting to
you i have a i have a weird highlight i
feel like tell me and i guess it's i
guess it's not as weird as you with the
the rocks pecks but um
the saints row demo i don't know why i
care so much all you are all you're
doing is creating a character in it but
but they have great character grades
yeah to see that pop up and be like
available now and i'm nowhere near my
console so i can't take advantage of it
but that's still excited me a lot like i
think saints row is going to be a really
fun game and
shout out to them for not releasing on
the same day as eldon ring because that
would have been hilarious i was going to
say that's like a sliding doors moment
where they did that
but it's okay because horizon went a
week before yeah
still they still managed to do very well
for example horizon and forbidden we're
still still very good they're very good
at releasing uh
just move away from ultimate within
within whispers of something else that
will take a lot of attention bless their
hearts um just for me i got to see a
little bit more of which fire it looked
great
i'm i'm sold now looked really good
they were i mean the first time i
remember hearing about photogrammetry
was for the vanishing of ethan carter
like the the way to use photographs to
make your games look
way more photorealistic but not pay
through the nose for it and i was like
that's a fine looking game um
and i know you mentioned it beforehand
so i'm very stoked for you
i mean i just like it's just one of
those things there's like it's got
skeletons and magic in like dark looking
medieval stuff we were talking about
this but it's like yeah boomer shooters
are i mean they're i mean i don't know
if they're here to stay but they're back
um they're having a moment they're
having a moment and i you know dm 2016
has a lot of to thank for that but this
kind of really reminds me or at least
harkens to a very specific time in like
kind of the mid to late 90s where we had
dark
themed like like kind of darker fantasy
themed shooters we had games like blood
hexen um one and two we had the clive
barker game on dying
um
and
uh
painkiller painkiller was kind of like
the last one and like some of the devs
from painkiller are coming back for this
so like
this is look look even if this is just
like a boomer
boomer schoomer boomer shooter
reskin
uh sort of deal
um
but look at this dark fantasy medieval
stuff going down it's like it's a mix of
powers that i really love it's like look
at that it's just like that real uh that
power fantasy exactly that's what these
games are made for and like the the doom
like
quick
quick step to the side i'm very down
also like i said it's just like
vanishing ethan carter
for that game with no guns yeah
investigate little ghost stories to
shooting ghost stories yeah making your
own ghost totally different but
i'm with it you know
all right well i think today was a
pretty fantastic kickoff to summer game
fest jeff keeley your shoes look like
gene simmons kicks and i'd dig it it was
like from afar you were like
they were shining yeah you were the
demon himself not like you know the kiss
kiss demon gene simmons that's what i'm
talking about i'm gonna stop talking i'm
over it all i'm saying is like
good work you did good you expect if
there's any expectation i needed to be
filled from key three other than you
know seeing a lot of cool games
it was what shoes you were going to be
wearing
um as mentioned this is only the
beginning of a few days of stuff to come
it's just the start just the start we
have day of the devs happening currently
we're probably going to kick it over to
in a second how are we feeling john luke
got a thumbs up
um
and
don't go anywhere i mean watch it but
tune back because devonta and i are
going to close out the day the first day
lucy and tam are not
going to be joining us
um as far as that's because they're cool
cats for their own cool schedules we're
seeing gains
look at us
we're out on the field
celebrating games yes and also yes keep
in mind if you're here if you're
watching game spots content on summer
game fest everything we're going to be
breaking out a bunch of stuff interviews
and hands-on stuff uh both from lucy
james and to more and more to more and
more and others uh so be on the lookout
uh please here
that game spot um
i just want to say you all did great
thanks
thanks thank you
in the celebration and celebration of
games it's the festival games my dear
friends
um
all right
let's kick it over thank you everyone
that's me that's you
enjoying you enjoy be cool be sweet play
games like stuff stay focused i'm
current divina this is gamespot or the
day of the devs see you folks
[Music]
and now i am very pleased to present a
world premiere from our friends at us
two games the folks who brought you
monument valley alba and a bunch of
other really really cool games
here it is
[Music]
at those two games we really try and
take what's meaningful and great about
games and deliver that to everybody so
with monument valley we make people care
about a character for the first time if
they've never really engaged with games
very much and with alba wildlife
adventure we took open world games and
packaged that into a kind of theme about
saving an island that more people are
going to want to engage with than just a
hardcore and with this game what we
really want to do is take these genres
that we really love like roguelike games
and turn-based tactics add a little bit
of sports game in there as well and
themes about dreams and conflicting
fears and really package that together
into something that feels really unique
in the game you play the role of dester
he's a young person in their early 20s
he's coming home for the first time
having not left home in their the very
best way their relationship with their
mother and their family and their
friends there's a few of them that were
a little bit broken and they were broken
because they didn't really have the
words to say and their father who used
to be a big part of their life
unfortunately passes away and they don't
have those tools and that person to lean
on to to bridge that gap
so they managed to go home they find
this old ball they use to play with
their dad and when they try and fall
asleep with it they find themselves in a
world between worlds neither asleep nor
awake and when they're in this they can
explore these moments these memories and
solve these creative problems through a
through a ball game and when they do
that they find the right words to say to
confront these people
the people we're going to be meeting in
dust's dreams are people who were
significant to testa before they left
town a couple of years back
and there are lots of people they don't
know quite as well too and some people
who have been shaped by desta's
impression of them in their dreams but
they've all had a profound impact on
dustin's life
these characters are really interesting
because all of them are interwoven as
part of dusty's story but also with each
other
they don't just appear as abstractions
but they really feel like a part of the
makeup of desti's background
one way or another the people that
decimate throughout the game helped
desta become who they are today and
they've taught us to a number of
different things like standing up for
themselves taking risks expressing
themselves and more there are a few
different themes in the story but i
would say that certainly loss is a big
part of it
finding yourself courage and
perseverance and free awakening no pun
intended
it feels like we've been able to put a
lot of our ourselves into desta um the
same is true for pretty much all of our
games but desta in particular is very
personal to a lot of the members of the
team and i'm sure we can all relate to
some of the themes of maybe having
ghosted a friend and not being sure how
you could like get back in touch with
them or
dwelling over how you might have said
something in a conversation and like
having that play over and over in your
mind which is like one of the core
themes of the game it's definitely got
more depth and more game mechanics than
anything we've made before and it's
being designed from the ground up to be
a multi-platform title we're really
looking forward to telling you more
about destin the memories between in the
coming weeks and the coming months
[Music]
this next game is called shim it's a
shadow platformer you're a little blobby
character platforming around inside
shadows and a game with a really cool
minimalist graphic art style i hope you
like it
hi i'm about and i'm the developer of
zip and i'm nils from exonize and i help
avo develop skim we're located in the
north of the netherlands in a town
called leoware we are a team of two plus
the talented people at moon celebrity
audio
[Music]
same as a game where you move around in
shadows
you play as a script a shadow
[Music]
creature as a whole stream is made to be
approachable for a variety of players at
its core it's about jumping around in
shadows and platforming towards the end
of the level
[Music]
each shadow has our own skin
the player plays around as a scream of a
human however this team is separated
from that person and it's up to you to
find your way back
[Music]
in the game you will also help other
scam characters who have also been
separated on their shadow
you can help them by finding their
object
skimp takes big inspiration from the
feeling of playing as a child
playing imaginary games with made-up
rules move around in shadows and jump to
the next shadow
[Music]
so
check it out and follow us at
shrimpgame.com
[Music]
hi everyone and thank you deb that's
having us this year i'm the manager of
asabu a community hub for indie game
creators in tokyo we have a space where
people can come to work and meet other
people do small gatherings and we are
helping japanese devs by introducing
them to platforms console publishers
helping them on marketing or as usually
they don't speak english helping them to
apply to overseas events like this one
and we're also doing a lot of online
contents and streams
like our big associated showcase which
will be aired this summer in english and
japanese or a monthly stream in the
collection and podcasts and many other
things you can check on youtube and
twitch
but first let's check two really cool
japanese titles
[Music]
[Applause]
fox and frog travelers the demand of
arashino island is a 3d action adventure
game with a japanese-inspired atmosphere
you will play as [__] her goal will
find herself on arashino island and
starts traveling with frog
[Music]
torii gates who stole lantern and neon
gives light and color to the island but
something is lurking in the shadows
inching even clogger
[Applause]
[Music]
fox and frog travelers is developed by
rheas an illustrator and concept artist
that came up with the idea for it based
on one of his illustrations
[Music]
fox and frog long journey through the
night is planned for release in a few
years
[Music]
oh
first game of the young solo developer
yo fuji goodbye world is a narrative
game about two young indian game
creators the shaikhani and the extrovert
comedy
[Music]
mixing influences from comics like ghost
world and games like the beginner's
guide or moses iii
goodbye world is a tale about the
passion and struggle that comes with
game creation
through 13 chapters of the story
rendered in beautiful pixel art in a
resolution close to the super ness and
game boy advance
[Music]
goodbye world is you out on steam later
this year if you like this game don't
hesitate to wishlist and to follow that
on twitter and if you are interested by
a japanese indie scene or indie games
you can follow us on twitter on discord
chat with us and watch our indie game
showcase which is coming this summer
and thank you again for watching and day
of the day for having us
[Music]
the process of moving to a new city can
be daunting our next game birth from
solo developer madison carr who hails
from chicago explores the idea of
quelling loneliness through this puzzle
adventure
hi my name is madison and i'm making a
game called birth
[Music]
[Applause]
birth is a point-and-click puzzle game
about living alone in a large city
[Music]
in order to quell your loneliness you
decide to create a creature a friend a
partner for yourself by collecting spare
bones and organs that you find while
traversing the city
[Music]
you will explore libraries and post
offices and museums and cafes and
apartments that don't belong to you
[Music]
in each of these buildings you will meet
creatures and you will get to know them
by searching through their personal
belongings
their laptops and phones their cabinets
and their notebooks
[Music]
within these personal belongings there
are puzzles
some are physics-based some are
pattern-based
some are abstract
there are no instructions and you are
rarely doing the same thing twice
[Music]
alongside the main game there are
optional hidden tokens that you can find
to unlock secret buildings and treasures
birth comes out this august i made this
game with my whole heart and i hope that
you like it
[Music]
in our next title how to say goodbye you
play as the ghost of a person who's
recently died and is embarking on the
journey of accepting their own death
the mechanics underscore the message
that there's always a way through grief
you may get stuck but you can always
stop
re-evaluate and keep moving it's all
just part of the puzzle
hi i'm florian co-author of the upcoming
narrative puzzle game how to say goodbye
[Music]
in how to say goodbye you help a group
of quirky ghosts overcome various
obstacles and conundrums by reorganizing
the level as you like
[Music]
moving one tile will also push the
surrounding tiles
[Music]
the puzzle elements are only moved
around but never removed so just like a
rubik's cube the puzzles never end up in
a state where you can't solve them
[Music]
follow various characters looking to
discover why they are still here and how
to move on while trying to escape the
grasp of an evil wizard who doesn't know
how to let go
[Music]
how to say goodbye tells a story of loss
and grief but we intend the experience
to be as gentle kind and positive as
possible
if this sounds like something that you
would be interested in
please wishlist the game it would mean a
lot to us thank you
[Music]
oh
hi
well wasn't that a great show and a
great cake and it's all gone and so now
we have to say goodbye i hope you liked
that i hope you liked all the games
thank you to all the developers
for making such fantastic games and for
bringing them here for everyone to enjoy
special thanks to all of our generous
sponsors you've always been there for us
and we could not do this without you
playstation
idea xbox nintendo
steam epic game store y'all are awesome
thank you extra special thanks to dos
one the magic man for supplying all the
beats and sound effects and tunes you
hear in every summer game fest edition
of day of the devs
we couldn't have done any of this
without you
or at least it'd be really quiet
and kind of suck we're not done with the
day of the dev 10th anniversary just yet
if you go to day of thedevs.com and sign
up for our newsletter you will be
amongst the first to hear about all the
excitement that's to come this year
other than that thank you so much to
everybody who watched and we'll see you
next year bye
we'll see you next time aha you thought
it was over but it is actually not day
the devs continues with a special after
party performance by the one and only
peter berkman of onomatoguchi fame he's
debuting new music from a game you've
probably never heard of it's called
little nemo and the guardians of
slumberland and the reason you haven't
heard of it is because it's debuting on
kickstarter at this
very freaking moment
enjoy see you later thanks for tuning in
to day of the devs summer game fest
edition bye
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
come on
[Music]
[Applause]
more
[Music]
so
thank you
[Music]
woah
um
[Music]
[Applause]
my
[Music]
ah
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
do
so
[Music]
huh
so
[Music]
um
god
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
my
[Music]
okay
hey
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
[Applause]
[Music]
me
bye
[Applause]
[Music]
my
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
hmm
foreign
[Music]
or uh game spots coverage of summer game
fest but summer game fest that big old
presentation with jeff keely happened
just a few hours ago we had dave the
devs but now coming up we have devolvers
marketing countdown to marketing
happen what
3 p.m just she's just got like 15
minutes for us to chit chatting i'm
joined here today with davonte chisholm
hello came in from new jersey across the
coast across the ways here's
some would say it's the best state
but you didn't hear that from me i sure
didn't
as an east coaster from new york
my my lineage starts here in san
francisco california anyways thank you
folks for being here so today we're just
going to kind of powwow we don't really
know devol we don't really ever know
what devolver is doing um and i think
it's better that way yeah i'd rather
have it that way uh it's in devolver's
spirit to
kind of get exactly what we know we're
gonna get for them which is
extreme
over the top extreme weird um satirical
yeah something like torn right out of
the robocop universe
it's like i'll buy that for a dollar
yeah but uh we're a devolver i just have
to say i don't know about you devante
i love devolver i love what they do with
their streams i love what they do i love
for as as as
obnoxious as
as they could be uh they're at least
they're one of the only ones doing in
fact they're the only ones doing and in
the midst of people
just i've i've been watching these i've
been watching these for a long time we
know like we know what we're getting big
trailers big numbers big reveals world
premieres
and devolver
knows that leans into it hard
but today's a an exciting one for me
because suda51 a man uh a designer whom
i admire quite a bit i've actually been
going down every single game he's made
recently starting with well the big ones
the ones these you know grasshoppers
starting with silver case onto the 25th
award so i have no idea why he's here
other than it's the most devolver thing
imaginable yeah but it's it's awesome
because it's
it's still a celebration of video games
even if they are
making fun of uh they're making fun of
a certain corner yeah they're making fun
of like the big business of it which is
inevitable those things have to exist
that's how we all operate that's how we
all function that's how they operate and
yeah
and that's kind of like the beauty or at
least like the beauty of it for me it's
like that kind of relieving like
it's good to be reminded in a way of
like yeah this is how it works and
devolver does it full force yeah and i
like even like
even though they do that
and their showcases look and and are the
way they are
the games aren't just completely goofy
over the top and things like that you
have such a wide variety of experiences
you can have with the things that they
publish well devolver has built a
character around their name
on their own yeah the fact that we're
even sitting here and talk and we're
choosing to talk about solely like the
devolver
like brand as devolver as a publisher
you don't really get that as much like
anna annapurna kind of like like the
annapurna raw fiery devolver kind of
like linger in like the space of like
above average that's the wrong word
above like this above par kind of like
you know smaller game showcase like
somewhere in like the double a space of
like indie games or that are like
on the fringe of doing something i think
if i think a good way to put is
even the gamers who kind of focus just
on the aaa releases i think you can look
at a list of things that like devolver
has published and they've probably still
heard of it yeah and if they claim
they're not into indie games it's like
oh yeah i've heard that play that and
stuff and with so much popping up on
game pass especially a bunch of devolver
games it's that store weird west
yeah you probably played a bunch of or
just even if it's for five minutes
and that's like that's the thing that
i'm kind of always a little like we've
talked we've already talked a lot about
devolver as a brand as an identity yeah
but like that's the thing is like
they as a publishing company um
like they're filling a certain space yep
uh they're filling a certain space like
with things like like inscription
and and like uh
even again like weird west which is a
game that i like a lot i played that
game quite a bit i gotta get back to it
you can do whatever you want you can
play whatever you want there's all sorts
of things i think i could play it late
at night and it was a lot of reading and
i was like i'm tired so i gotta go what
is this
don't play a suit of 51 game then don't
play an early super 51 game because
they're basically novels yeah they're
just novels but that's the thing is like
we sit here like i have absolutely no
idea what we're going to see i know
we're going to see a spectacle of
devolver wackiness where we're probably
also going to our new favorite games
possibly 2020 there's that's the chance
the role of the dice and like in the
midst of things where we're seeing like
big world premieres and aliens dark
descent and uh the last of us remake
part one because they're all protocols
which are all beautiful things i'm happy
to see i can at least kind of devolve or
give me something like oh i didn't know
i wanted that
but i'm glad it's here but i'm glad it's
here i'm glad it's here i put in um
i uh
i don't know if suda51 is actually gonna
be announcing anything relative to
devolver um
i mean no more heroes three only came
out
last year was it last year
yeah i think so i don't know maybe
you're a big suda fan
huge huge the biggest tell me your
favorite game um
you know it was it was that one and it
has a really special place in my life
because of the things i was going
through at the time that it released
fantastic
absolutely fantastic yeah yeah yeah i
like that one what about yeah what about
yours oh well uh
no but i wanted to keep talking keep
telling me about your favorite suit what
was it about you know what was it you
know you know there was a character and
that character
um
dealt with a struggle that
they had to overcome and as the player i
i overcame it and really felt things at
the end yes yeah yeah
yeah
[Laughter]
uh student 51 so there's a game called
the silver game i'm just gonna take this
opportunity to talk about student games
that i love uh the silver case is a game
that i played recently i'm just gonna
take this opportunity if there's any
chance for the silver case universe to
come back we've had a few we've had a
few games we have the 25th ward suit 51
joint flower sun rain
is killer 7 in that kill the past
i think i'm totally exposing myself
as a fan right now i mean you did say
that you're like just starting to like
play it i'm going through i'm going from
the start i'm going through it's like i
played no more heroes uh i played
shadows of the damned yeah um
like i've i can't even imagine
possibly like a suda is such a character
and it's such a curt like it's such like
a presence a rock star as they call them
in the industry
um but i'm excited it only makes sense
if there's any personality to be
attached to devolver today
it's suda and you said he's going to be
a mech sure earnest sure they like they
they they in the teaser they showed off
there was a lot of screaming
which is always appropriate for devolver
yep um
and it ended with pseudo coming out of a
mech out of like at 209 again robocop
kind of themed thing going that they
have going for themselves
okay so we can only see we can hold only
hope and speculate because with devolver
it's it's we don't really know well last
year hold on let's actually give us
something last year they had the um
what was it the the entire presentation
was on a vhs
was it was last year the one with like
the pluses and the different
subscriptions sure is that the one
before it i think all of them blend i
think all of them are just like a fever
dream of marketing and things that are
coming out no i think it was last year
they uh they had the entire presentation
on a vhs that i think was up for sale
after the fact
there was another and then there was a
game that was going to be released
physically only which i was like as
someone who doesn't own like who made a
deliberate choice at one point in his
life did not own anything i was there
for some reason i was like
hell yeah i was like for some reason i
was all bored and like i remember jordan
may on our team
bless his heart he's a great dude he's
like kurt that's stupid and i was like
no it's great it's the most it's the
it's the it's it's it makes this thing
meaningful it's the most evolver thing
that could possibly happen think of the
ebay uh resale the bubble
yeah
it's the only reason i would have it the
bubble needs to pop
like this bubble's about to pop we got
five minutes coming in but i just want
to let everyone know uh you're watching
game spot i'm kurt devina joined with
devante chisholm we're doing coverage
all week all weekend all week for summer
games fest all things relative
so tomorrow we got uh
there's a lot of things happening we
have trebek wow try back to rebecca
tomorrow um but then the big one sunday
with the xbox showcase the xbox and
bethesda showcase where i will be joined
myself devante lucy james moore hussein
will be joining us to go over a pre-show
and post show and all that supposed to
be a big one and of course there's going
to be a follow-up happening uh for the
xbox but that's the showcase later that
week too so clearly they have something
in store devolver has a pretty good way
of getting a lot of their games on xbox
game pass so there's somewhat of a segue
there and i'm excited to see
um if there's anything any surprises
that we're able to go back home to and
just jump into with the power of game
pass
i
i just saw something i also just saw it
on on this like list of upcoming games
cult of the lamb
um is a game i've been interested in and
i i kind of forgot about it for for a
little bit but maybe we might see some
more of that today and get a date for it
because it's still tbd so
that should be interesting
what else you see what else you got
i'm
one thing i will say is i'm kind of
hoping that we don't see too much fall
guys at this oh that's right like we've
already we've already saw that
we already saw the commercial at
the last um
event that took place
this summer summer game fest live um
so i i hope we don't really dwell on it
too long like it's great that it's free
to play
soon
and it's coming to more consoles but
i don't think we need to spend any time
on it unless
there's some weird like
death door
costume
or something dlc
possibly dlc you never know i think
there might be a new season or something
coming up but either way
don't spend too much time on it um
give me yeah give me
cult of the lamb
something and then
something whatever else you want to show
go for it if suda is enough if like
student takes this opportunity to
announce a new game like i will like i'm
not going to make any promises mm-hmm
well i'll be excited
oh i said i was going to say something
like i was going to punch myself in the
face
what i was hearing was you're gonna get
up and do a dance okay i gotta kick
forever real high you're gonna like be
on top of the desk if suda 51 announces
a new game okay through revolver yes
i'll do a high kick okay and it'll be
the one of the best high kicks you've
ever seen but you have to come to the
post show in order to see that
um but i think also while we're on that
topic the post show
um
you guys if you folks stick around which
you should stick around here game spot
uh that's gonna be the closeout for the
day so after devolver
you're all free to take a nap you can
all go to sleep yes you can you can all
uh think about you can dream about all
the things you saw today and dream about
what you wish or what you could be
seeing
for the days to come yeah
like
god of war
xbox excuse me
all day
you've been waiting all day to do that
if there was any if there was any moment
in which you would want to say that
it would probably be right before the
devolver
yeah i guess so i mean i was also just
probably gonna save it for sunday just
to be that guy
right before xbox starts you know just
to upset the chat and just be like god
of war ragnarok can't wait to see it
forget fable forget forza
god of war
i'm just i'm just looking out for those
uh
those silent hill rumors
silent hill at devolver here we go in
one minute you could breathe in a
certain direction someone will think
it's a silent hill rumor silk song is
going to be at devolver oh don't
don't ruin jordan speaking jordan or may
has been brought up twice during this
pour his little heart he'll probably
take anything he can get yeah at this
point all right we're closing in a
minute and a half um
while this wow this prediction
while this prediction um i just had one
in mind what what game was that uh
katana zero
two okay i don't know why
i didn't even beat the first one so i
don't really know how it ends or if it
lends itself to a sequel but that's
that's what i'm looking at here this is
this isn't a wild prediction what i want
i sincerely want i want inscription on
consoles i want inscription on i
switched
it wasn't on consoles yeah that's what i
really want
why not just just get a steam deck just
play okay all right yeah let me just you
know we all have one yeah yeah okay
everybody watching right now has a steam
deck yeah of course yeah but
so stupid if i i have it in my pocket
right now i really show it to everyone
but i don't want to make you jealous so
yeah so you can play your favorite uh
uh
suit of 51 games exactly all right folks
well now we're counting down into this
thing thank you so much for joining us
this is game spots coverage of all
things video games all things wonderful
uh we're gonna go over to the devolver
direct right now see you folks give a
flying [__] flip about the marketing
reports we are losing consumer attention
they are bored to show we've done
everything we can on that front the hell
you have zayn the hell you have
what you've done are worldwide
exclusives fancy transitions expensive
pre-recorded presentations fake live
events live live events and some gymshed
narrative garbage that didn't go
anywhere melissa data the data is clear
the industry analytics point to
fragmented attention in every consumer
focused vector but one and that is we've
got countdowns those ridiculous
30-minute celebrity soaked attention
grab countdowns before our company's
actual presentation actually starts
actually they are big dumb wasteful
empty and
they work she's right i'm gonna lie of
course i'm [__] right
so this year we're counting down
that's the focus the countdown it's all
about the countdown no holds barred
anything goes all stops pulled out of
where the [__] stops are that people
keep pulling them out of yeah okay sure
but what are we counting down to like
what happens when we get to zero
it
doesn't [__] matter you can propose
to your mistress for all i care i just
want big number consumer eyeballs drying
out as they watch a marketing laden
countdown where we're drip feeding them
brand awareness and purchase intent
until they climax and their g fuel
soaked gamer chairs no not yet gross i'm
getting it though
so who do we have on deck to host this
thing i mean we need someone right
can we do a celebrity
can we get james van der beek team pacey
huh i'm just saying to the people a
giant [__] robot with whoever the
[__] we want inside of it hosting our
show inside of it hosting our show
i'm sorry what hold
we've designed developed and deployed a
wideband interlocal net modulated
telepresence experience through which a
virtual host can virtually host our
virtually hosted countdown broadcast
so what like a zoom call no no not like
a zoom margaret now
[Music]
what the [__] is that
what's up
[Laughter]
[Music]
you
foreign
let me see if we can get you some kind
of a break from the numerals match
my name's margaret shut up madge does
this
does this thing uh
i'm sorry
does this thing have access to the feeds
yes it has access to the feed all feeds
every the feeds on the planet hiking
even deep into trans local space with a
little extra juice you could even
transmit all the way sure yeah can it uh
can he
can he do trailers
yes
trailers number station beats launch
codes replicant inception satellite
destruct instructions suggestive
tick-tock dances the basics it's also
equipped with the tricordal
thermonuclear essential mass
displacement cannon
hot stuff uh give me the button
okay yeah sure whatever
let's see you and i put the marketing
into the devolver digital marketing
countdown to marketing and give the fine
audience at home something to throw
money at their screens
and we use it to hawk a video
[Music]
sister game
[Applause]
hmm
[Music]
hello
oh
come here
[Music]
so
no we didn't make that massive monster
made it yeah people are going to be
obsessed when it drops
well no not just the videos
we're the publisher
we publish the games that's important
stuff you know it's basically the same
thing as making the games without all
the you know effort creativity time
energy that goes into making said game
i think of us as a humanitarian service
like fema or crocs you guys see the
numbers that sheep game or whatever did
us a duper mad spike wild stuff really
wild
stuff it tastes like baby food
have you guys seen the numbers i know
right no you don't know
what do you know i know the numbers keep
going like this i'm gonna buy a house
what's going on is it working on the
[__] moon like pre-sales engagement
but these numbers are like nothing we've
ever seen well that's good though right
too good neither these numbers are like
nothing anyone has seen something's
wrong we need to tell hazel this needs
to stop whoa whoa oh there's sports just
crawl up all your little horses take a
breath make some sense what i'm saying
is that it doesn't make sense it can't
make sense according to the tracking
we're just you guys [__] with the
numbers
no one's [__] with anything we just
rolled a [__] hot trail what the holy
heck is going on with these numbers
at the end of 2001 with a gigantic
jupiter space baby dave's all shriveled
up and the computer's going now it's
like
of hope to trip
[Music]
so what's with the numbers
no
[Music]
there's no comp in that that was an
accident holy butt's another engagement
spike the chat's going nuts our social
mind share ratings and marketing
relevancy are shooting through the roof
somebody tell me what the [__] is going
on moon house a [__] house on the
moon what if it's it's the yeah yeah
that's great what if it's the death no
yeah what if it's the trailers
your big dumb robot uh do you think
[Music]
oh okay
yeah i was thinking something a little
more along like yeah
knew it let's
make sure
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
yeah another massive spike like big time
massive what do the numbers look like
though they just just keep going up it's
absolutely insane this isn't real this
can't be real it's like some kind of
video game
no
no it can't be did you just say video
game singularity oh my god wait what are
we talking about right
video now singularity is a hypothetical
moment of absolute corporate convergence
an event horizon into which
kaleidoscopically manifold fractionated
conglomerate interests are inescapably
pulled
and at a single point of infinite
density
compressed against the entropic
inevitability of like i don't know years
of inter-industry corporate mergers
acquisitions between developers
publishers platform holders and soulless
holding companies
everyone buying merging with and
acquiring everyone else until the only
[__] thing left anymore is one giant
thick throbbing
ultraman omni company eating up
everything in its way it can't be
bargained with it can't be reasoned with
it doesn't feel pity or remorse or fear
and it absolutely will not stop ever
until everything is one thing and that
one thing is
everything and that thing is us
oh god oh jesus christ so two moon
houses you're not getting insane imagine
all platforms all iconic characters all
methods of monetization
all hot balled up into one monopolistic
origin of interactive video
entertainment imagine streaming your
favorite prequel as a service on on on
your virtual phone while you're sitting
on a toilet in a in a metaverse taco
bell while you while you have sonic the
hedgehog in a committed non-monogamous
relationship with with that huge lady
from resident evil and they are they
could be playing apex fort zone on an
atari dream station 64. and it would all
be free to play or play the arm
how did this happen
it's the mech
[Music]
you guys
you guys follow the directions right
oh of course
well
[Music]
so
once upon a time there was a plucky
squire named jot
jot roamed the land in search of
adventure
battling beasts
helping the helpless
and generally being very heroic
but then one day he discovered something
rather curious
a world he never knew existed
foreign
i can't tell if it's just that these
games are amazing or if it's what the
[__] happened to my shirt
what's going on
is this the singularity i just got sent
a review copy of metal gear cooking mama
mobile i don't even know what that means
do you even know what that means the
industry's folding in on itself dude
it slaps real hard 10 out of 10. that's
not the point
g fuel just put in an offer to buy valve
microsoft bought bethesda again
just for fun just what the ever shooting
[__] fire have you [__] done now oh
um uh bucky squire we just did the
plucky squire thing yeah it was legit
the sauce to my robot what have you done
to my goddamn robot and what's with your
shirt it's the singularity
but what is the problem
the video game singularity
somehow this big dumb whatever the [__]
is channeling egregious amounts of hype
and marketing power into a single point
and everything is converging on that
point right here so what is the problem
soon devolver digital ink will become
the sole arbiter of all video games and
everything that goes along with it alone
single mega platform with total and
unstoppable absolute command over
everything
so what is the problem
[Music]
we don't know what we're doing
the devolver barely functions as a
marginally successful video game
publisher we can't be the
central ordinal nexus of all industry
why not
[Music]
i
[Applause]
[Music]
this
[Applause]
[Music]
jesus annapurna interactive just merged
with mountain dew [__] they're gonna
make a soft drink out of journey
it's not going to stop
the hype is too great
we made a countdown with nothing at the
end just to get viewers and built a
machine we don't understand to do the
counting down we were so preoccupied
with whether or not we could we didn't
stop to think if we should
we can't stop counting it can't even
stop itself counting this machine
is a mecca
first it will be devolver then it will
be everything we won't even
what the
inversion actualized
listen
listen you have to listen to me the only
way out of this is
[Applause]
in the beginning
it is always dark
a single loot box coin
it is all that remains in my vast empire
[Music]
yes
no
it hasn't
video games can rise again
and you
and your dreams and wishes
open your hand
[Music]
what are you going to wish for
wakaranai
then there will be no more video games
anymore
[Music]
as many as you want
and the more wishes you make the more
magnificent video games will become
until
try it
[Music]
this is not in the contract this is
nowhere in the contract
well he got some [__]
[Music]
[Applause]
merging with an infinite totality
of corporations
[Music]
you live
my
[Music]
lose yourself in my eyes
i loved every
game they said that's this is the thing
all right like devolver
i wanna i almost wanna know when they're
not gonna do what they do i'm waiting
for the day when they decide to like
go left and just completely like give us
the opposite of something that's so
rambunctious but
they put on a show
that makes heavy-handed commentary
but they also show every single game
that they showed today looked like if we
were sitting here being like oh i want
to play that yep i want to play that i
want to play that so you even said it
also by the way if you if you tuned in
before i was going to i said i was going
to do a high kick if a suit of 51 game
was announced didn't happen you don't
get the pleasure of seeing it
it doesn't happen that doesn't mean it
won't happen that doesn't mean there
isn't an opportunity for a high kick
later this weekend but let's kick it off
first thing we saw from devolver was
called to the land which was the one and
only game you're like hey i think i know
about that game that's a game i'm
interested in checking out yeah talk
about it um like animal crossing
stardew valley don't starve yeah you
know
later i've been getting a little deeper
into the roguelites and stuff like that
so
this just
caught my eye a while ago when it was
first announced but there was no date
and now we have a date and a demo which
is awesome um so
demo right now on steam again you know
my steam deck right here
in my pocket i'm gonna download it later
but um yeah that's that's awesome you
pull it out i'll fight you for it can't
wait for that
can't wait to play that the full game on
august 11th um so it was good to finally
get it it was like
the classic cute bubbly style yeah it
was very awesome very very sinister yeah
it was big i thought they were going to
kill the pig it was basically a cult
cult uh you know collecting resources
and and things like that going on
fighting
but then right after that
right after that then we had anger foot
oh my favorite name my favorite game
title of 2022 has to be anger anger foot
it looks great and then with a title
like that flashing up while a crocodile
is twerking on screen come on come on
honestly like
i said it uh while it was happening but
it gave me
first person hotline miami vibes yeah it
gave me like this sort of like extremely
fast-paced extremely violent overly
stylized
character kicking doors open like
probably flipping doors open like
probably flipping through guns just
blasting things away it was outlined
miami but in first person and then they
actually show the main character then
who is like this like
he's green so he must be schematic
there's there's alligators in it so i'm
just going to sleep and driving with his
angry feet and yeah i want to play it in
vr too did they did i didn't miss that
i don't think there was the folks who
made it they made gorn which is a scene
it was a vr game interesting
vr as well they did general jousting
that one's a classic if you have if you
don't know look it up sincerely general
jousting one game like i legit
like all of us in this in the studio
were like whoa
what which was uh the plucky squire yeah
which started which is like started out
like in of itself like the opening the
trailer showed
this like this ornate almost like
i feel it was like giving andy toys like
i feel it was like giving andy toy story
exactly vibes and i went to this open
open children's book and then you
realize like the game itself was being
played on the pages of the children's
book well you still got to see the rest
of the desk and like the trailer was
leaning into it we were all like i was
like yeah that's so cool that's such a
cool stuff like i'm all in and the
moment he leaped off the page onto the
desk like
i got chills i was like holy
like what great reveal yeah like yeah
cool and to be able to jump back and
forth and you know be on a cup or any of
the other flat surfaces it's just giving
you the the link between worlds yeah
zelda link between worlds yeah mario
odyssey kind of still kind of
having it looks like like i was like i
was like are like making notes on the
side like all alright like this looks
great like i love the concept of like
you know it's like it's a 2d side
scroller that's fine yeah the moment
they the character left off left off the
page i was like damn
yeah sorry i
probably blew the mic i was just like
so that was like and then another banger
right after it was skate story
yeah apparently it's been shown before
like back in 2020 but
i don't think we've ever seen that much
of it
and to be made of glass and pain but you
must skate like
just those lines just mean wow yes
powerful i i need to i need to play the
way he shatters when he when he bails
there's that high there's something
there's something cool about like um
it's like it has that it clearly has the
skate like the gamsky kind of
you know one hit kill like you know like
one one mess up you're done you shatter
yeah but then there was like
enemies and like all these like things
there's like these things that he was
doing tricks around i didn't like
explosions yeah it was different spaces
it looked fantastic it was just like
every like just one after the other i
was like uh
all those major like games they showed i
was like
again i said this before in the pre-show
but every time i was like i walk into a
developer i was like we have no idea
what we're getting we never know where
we're getting from them as like an
identity and as a brand and we never
know where they're gonna be working on
our publishing yeah and every time i
walk away from a devolver show for the
most part that might be hyperbolic but
most of the time i walk away being like
seeing games i didn't know i needed yeah
um
and
coming like i already was like pretty
hyped off of summer game fest way to go
jeff keely way to go key three
came out swinging you gave us world
premieres you told us the temper
expectations and all of a sudden you're
like just kidding here's a game you ever
heard about here's here's this sci-fi
horror game before it solid yeah you
gave us a lot of space stuff here's
another metallica there's another uh
yeah here's another here's another
aliens game another horror game set in
sci-fi and like it was all great i was i
was super happy to see a lot of things
that came from that but like devolver
for me gave me this
like you always think like i was like oh
we didn't have
that kind of like really nerdy surgeons
of seeing something oh i was so excited
for this thing that you were
anticipating and i like when we were
watching some of the stuff that devolver
i was like i got that same feeling
from something i didn't know i needed
yeah like playing the squire and it's i
think another thing that kind of goes
into it is
i feel like we saw a lot of gameplay
with each one of those yeah whereas with
um the showcase earlier it was a decent
amount of just like trailer yeah you
know we got a lot of gameplay too call
of duty of course we got a whole level
protocol that still didn't do like a
bunch for me but
um
with this it's just like you you saw it
you saw it in action it was it was
really quick and it was just like here
here's why you want to check this out
and play it and i think that fed into
some of our hearts too i just think
devolver like for all their antics for
all like for all their movie references
and
uh shenanigans like
their play on
metaverses and acquisitions yeah like
it's it's tom clancy's animal crossing
it's a spectacle it's it's over the top
i love it i can't help it i just like i
can't help it like i just think it's so
well done and then on top of that their
ability to like create a
a show that is like
entertaining and of itself
and then also show games
that i was genuinely like that looks
compelling so even if you're confused by
the rest of it
you've still got some good trailers yeah
for you to keep you in there for you
folks watching who have no idea who
suda51 is i'm so sorry
this is a very very devolver niche thing
that you're like we're gonna throw it
and then like not even announce a game
that he's involved in yeah even cooler
even better no tease or anything that is
the most suita suit of thing
him he himself probably could have done
yeah um
but uh
we're coming to a close on today
but that doesn't mean the fun and antics
have stopped for us devante what was
your what was if you could wrap it up
what was the what was the single
thing you got the most excited about
today
single thing i got the most excited
about
would definitely be the plucky squad wow
it would definitely be that um
again
jumping off the book page
it it it blew us away so yeah we were
all we were all collectively like i
think that surprise is what really made
it like
yeah for me yeah i really even get to
get to see much of what else the game
was it looked like like like it looked
like almost like genres of mechanics
were like changing
uh depending what you were doing so
that's that's incredible yeah that's
what i'm gonna be dreaming dreaming
about thinking about when i go to sleep
tonight so boom plucky squire bam with
that on your steam deck you're pulling
on your pockets yeah that on my steam
deck that you're just used to have him
down there
um what about you
sitting here with you
oh
oh stop it man stop it i'm gonna have to
i'm gonna have to move here you know
sitting here with you
i was uh that was my favorite part um i
appreciate that yeah it has been it has
been a joy to host today day one
and get to to share in all these
fantastic trailers that's what's up
thank you all right my dear friends
thank you so much for tuning in for game
spots coverage
of
summer game fest 2022. don't forget uh
we have
lots more coming this week lots more to
see we have a lot of things happening
devante and i are going to be here quite
a bit so tune in make sure you're on the
schedule make sure you're just checking
back every once in a while we have
tribeca tribeca games tomorrow
which is gonna be an interesting
showcase if you um you folks at home can
actually play some of the games are
gonna be showing you're gonna be able to
stream it pay five dollars for a little
pass and uh you get some time with a
number of games they're gonna be showing
off and then of course the really the
big one
um is xbox bethesda showcase on sunday
which is going to be i'm going to tell
you the time to show up
just in a moment here i know what i'm
doing i'm a professional
9 30 a.m is when we're going to start 9
30 am pt california time uh is when
devonte myself are going to be joined
with lucy james and tamora hussein to
get prepped and ready for whatever that
is and then of course stick around for a
post show on that jazz so that said
closing out the day
you're all fantastic thank you so much
for being here
davonte you did great thank you you did
you did even better that's a lie
i can't accept that and i just want to
give one more shout out to jean-luc
seipke he's the man behind the camera
he's the man controlling this from afar
thank you
thank you friend
he's waving it's good all right folks go
home
or stay home if you're already home go
to sleep play a game
drink some water
be well i'm kurt that's devonte till
next time see you later
you